EXPEDITING- ACCELERATING THAT
THE- ASPIRATION OF REACHING
CARBON NEUTRALITY- EVEN BEFORE
TWENTY FORTY FIVE WHAT WOULD BE
THE POTENTIAL TRADE OFFS- IN
DIFFERENT SECTORS SO- BEFORE I
GO ANY FURTHER AND- INVITES A
VICE CHAIR CENTER BACKER TO GIVE
SOME OPENING REMARKS I WANT TO
SAY THAT TO. THAT TO DUE TO
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN SAFETY
CONSIDERATIONS ALL ARE
ENCOURAGED TO WATCH THE HEARING
FROM OUR LIVE STREAM ON THE
ASSEMBLY'SWEBSITE. WE WELL HAVE
A MODERATED TELEPHONE LINE.
AVAILABLE TO ASSIST WITH PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION THE PUBLIC MAY
PROVIDE COMMENT BY CALLING THE
FOLLOWING TOLL FREE NUMBER.
877-692-8957 THAT NUMBER AGAIN
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. WITH
THE ACCESS CODE. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO AGAIN THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. SO WHAT
THAT. CENTER BACKER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GET SOME OPENING REMARKS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR AB.
YEAH I'LL SEE MOST OF MY REMARKS
FOR THE MEETING WHICH WAS A
BECOME EVEN MORE APPARENT THAN
IT WAS BEFORE IN THE LAST SIX
MONTHS SINCE WE LAST GATHERED
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
TO LEAD THE THAT IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET THINGS DONE THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND I THINK THAT
AS A IT ADDED- URGENCY TO OUR
HEARINGS TODAY AND THROUGHOUT
THIS YEAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
CENTER BACKER. I'D LIKE TO
INVITE ANY OF THE OTHER. OKAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
WELCOME AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE A
- ALTHOUGH NOT A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER- HE
FLORA HAS REQUESTED THAT HE
PARTICIPATED IN THIS HEARING I
WANT TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLOOR SELECTS ANY. OKAY. OKAY
AND WE HAVE JUST BEEN JOINED BY
SENATOR SKINNER. CENTER WITH A
DO YOU HAVE ANY OPENING REMARKS
. THAT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SO
WE WILL GO RIGHT INTO- PANEL ONE
POTENTIAL PATHWAYS TO CARBON
TRELEGY WHEN A WELCOME- AMBER
MAHONE. A WITH ENERGY
ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMICS- TO GIVE
HER PRESENTATION ON PATHWAYS HER
REPORT ON PATHWAYS TO CARBON
NEUTRALITY- WELCOME MS MAHONEY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR
MURATSUCHI AND THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY ON THE TOPIC OF
ACHIEVING CLIMATE NEUTRALITY.
YEAH I ALSO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO YOUR
VIRTUALLY TODAY THAT SIMPLE
ACCOMMODATION HAS HELPED TO
REDUCE MY CARBON FOOTPRINT AND
THE CARBON FOOTPRINT OF THIS
HEARING. SO MY NAME IS AMBER
MAHONE I'M A PARTNER IN ENERGY
AND ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMICS ALSO
KNOWN AS EACH THREE. E. THREE IS
AN ENERGY CONSULTING AND
ANALYSIS FIRM THAT WORKS ACROSS
NORTH AMERICA TO SUPPORT OUR
CLIENTS IN EVALUATING AND
IMPLEMENTING CLEAN ENERGY
POLICIES AND TECHNOLOGIES. IN
CALIFORNIA WE WORK WITH ALL OF
THE STATE'S ENERGY AGENCIES
INCLUDING THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD THE ENERGY COMMISSION AND
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
. CURRENTLY MY TEAM IS
SUPPORTING THEIR RESOURCES
BOARD. IN PERFORMING AN IN DEPTH
EVALUATION OF THE KANEMI WIDE
CARBON NEUTRALITY SCENARIOS TO
INFORM THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
SCOPING PLAN. THIS INCLUDES TWO
SCENARIOS THAT A CHEAP CARBON
EACH HOLIDAY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. AS WELL AS TWO SCENARIOS
THAT ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY
BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. THE TEAM
WILL BE PRESENTING SOME OF OUR
PRELIMINARY MODELING RESULTS IN
A PUBLIC WORKSHOP NEXT WEEK ON
TUESDAY MARCH FIFTEENTH. WE ALSO
PERFORM THE ELECTRIC SECTOR
MODELING FOR THE JOINT AGENCY SB
ONE HUNDRED CLEAN ELECTRICITY
ANALYSIS AND ARE SUPPORTING THE
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANNING. OR
ERP PROCEEDING AT THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
OVER THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS THAT
YOU THREE. MY TEAM AND I HAVE
CONDUCTED CONDUCTED MANY STUDIES
EVALUATING GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION STRATEGIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. INCLUDING IN CALIFORNIA
NEW ENGLAND NEW YORK THE PACIFIC
NORTHWEST MINNESOTA COLORADO AND
ELSEWHERE. IN TWENTY TWENTY MY
TEAM AND I RELEASED A REPORT ON
ACHIEVING CARBON NEUTRALITY IN
CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD SPONSORED THAT
STUDY TO GATHER INFORMATION IN
ADVANCE OF THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
SCOPING PLAN. ABOUT POTENTIAL
PATHWAYS AND POLICIES TO HELP
THE STATE ACHIEVE CARBON
NEUTRALITY FOR TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. WELL MY TESTIMONY IT
REFLECTS MY PERSONAL VIEWS ON
THIS TOPIC. THESE PERSPECTIVES
AND OF COURSE BEEN SHAPED BY
THAT EXTENSIVE BODY OF WORK WITH
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS NORTH
AMERICA. I'D LIKE TO MAKE THREE
KEY POINTS TO THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. FIRST CALIFORNIA HAS SET
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS
INCLUDING THE 40% GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION REQUIREMENTS BY TWENTY
THIRTY AND THE GOAL OF CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
. CARBON NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE IS BEING FURTHER
EVALUATED AS PART OF THE SCOPING
PLAN EFFORT THAT I MENTIONED
WHICH IS CURRENTLY UNDER WAY.
SECOND ACHIEVING CARBON
NEUTRALITY IS LARGELY A PHYSICAL
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE CHALLENGE
WHICH REQUIRES A WHOLESALE
TRANSFORMATION OF THE WAYS WE
PRODUCE AND USE ENERGY. THIRD
AND FINALLY. WELL CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE GOALS ARE AMBITIOUS WE
DON'T YET HAVE ALL OF THE POLICY
REGULATORY AND FINANCING
MECHANISMS IN PLACE TO IMPLEMENT
THIS AMBITIOUS AGENDA. WHAT DO I
MEAN BY THE PHYSICAL ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE CHALLENGE OF
ACHIEVING CARBON NEUTRALITY.
THIS MEANS THAT THE TIMING FOR
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA. HANDS
ON HOW QUICKLY THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. IN MILLIONS OF DIESEL
TRUCKS ON THE ROAD TODAY CAN BE
REPLACED BY ELECTRIC AND ZERO
EMISSION ALTERNATIVES. IT ALSO
DEPENDS ON HOW QUICKLY THE
FIFTEEN MILLION OR SO HOMES AND
MILLIONS OF BUSINESSES AND
INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES IN THE
STATE. CAN BE RETROFIT TO USE
CLEAN ELECTRICITY AND OTHER ZERO
CARBON FUELS FOR SPACE AND WATER
HEATING INTO POWER A WIDE
VARIETY OF INDUSTRIAL PROCESS
THESE. AND IT DEPENDS ON HOW
QUICKLY ALL KINDS OF OTHER NEW
ZERO CARBON ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL TECHNOLOGIES CAN
BE BUILT AND DEPLOYED. ACHIEVING
CARBON NEUTRALITY IS AS LIKELY
TO DEPEND ON MONDAY IN CHOICES
LIKE WHAT KIND OF CAR YOU AND
YOUR NEIGHBOR DRIVE. AND HOW
MANY YEARS YOUR NEIGHBORS
GASOLINE CAR REMAINS ON THE
ROAD. AS IT DOES ON INDUSTRIAL
ENERGY SUPPLY CHOICES AND THE
PACE OF RENEWABLE AND ZERO
CARBON ELECTRICITY DEPLOYMENT.
IN OUR TWENTY TWENTY MODELING
WORK WE EVALUATED THREE
SCENARIOS THE CHIEF CARBON
NEUTRALITY IN CALIFORNIA BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. THE MOST
AMBITIOUS OF THE SCENARIOS
ASSUME THAT ALL FOSSIL FUEL
EMISSIONS COULD BE ELIMINATED.
BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE. THROUGH
THE FOLLOWING MEASURES A RAPID
TRANSITION 21100% ALL ELECTRIC
AND ZERO EMISSION SALES FOR
VEHICLES AND BUILDING EQUIPMENT
BY TWENTY THIRTY. IN ADDITION WE
ASSUMED WIDESPREAD PRODUCTION
AND USE A ZERO CARBON
ELECTRICITY RENEWABLY PRODUCED
HYDROGEN CARBON CAPTURE AND
SEQUESTRATION. AND OTHER
ADVANCED BIO FUELS ALONG WITH
OTHER GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCING
MEASURES IN SECTORS LIKE WASTE
AGRICULTURE AND FROM OTHER
SOURCES OF HIGH GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL GASES. IN ADDITION IN
ALL OF THE CITY AREAS THAT WE
EVALUATED EVEN WITH AMBITIOUS
STEPS TO REDUCE FOSSIL FUEL USE
. CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL SUCH AS
LAND BASED CARBON SEQUESTRATION
AND DIRECT AIR CAPTURE OF CO TWO
WAS FOUND TO BE A CRITICAL
STRATEGY NEEDED TO ACHIEVE
CARBON NEUTRALITY. DESPITE BEING
IN THE VERY EARLY STAGES OF
COMMERCIALIZATION TODAY. THE
STUDY SHOWED THAT ACHIEVING
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE IN CALIFORNIA
REQUIRES AMBITIOUS NEAR TERM
ACTIONS AROUND DEPLOYMENT AND
ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
TRANSPORTATION AND BUILDING
ELECTRIFICATION ZERO CARBON
ELECTRICITY AND REDUCTIONS IN
NON ENERGY NON COMBUSTION
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AS NO
REGRETS STRATEGIES. IFWE LOOK
BACK ON THE LAST TEN YEARS OF
CLIMATE POLICY IN CALIFORNIA.
ERIC LEE THE LARGEST DRIVER OF
SUCCESS FOR A CHEATING
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY TWENTY
CLIMATE GOALS FOR YEARS AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE K. FROM GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS IN THE ELECTRIC POWER
SECTOR. THIS WAS PRIMARILY
DRIVEN BY THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD. CRITICALLY
THIS LAW CAME WITH A BUILT IN
FINANCING MECHANISM. IN THE FORM
OF INVESTOR AND MUNICIPALLY
OWNED UTILITIES AND ELECTRIC
REPAIRS. IN ADDITION BUILDING
CODES AND STANDARDS RATEPAYER
FUNDED ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROGRAMS AND VEHICLE FUEL
ECONOMY STANDARDS HAVE ALSO BEEN
CRITICAL IN REDUCING ENERGY
DEMAND ACROSS THE STATE. THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD AND THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM HAVE ALSO BOTH
PROVIDED IMPORTANT INCENTIVES IN
FUNDING FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLE
ADOPTION AND OTHER CARBON
REDUCING MEASURES. SO LOOKING
FORWARD WE KNOW THAT ACHIEVING
DEEPER LEVELS OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS WILL REQUIRE NEW
COMPLEMENTARY POLICIES AND
SIGNIFICANT CAPITAL INVESTMENTS
ACROSS EVERY SECTOR. THE DATA
ARE CLEAR THAT REDUCING
EMISSIONS FROM THE ELECTRIC
SECTOR ALONE WILL NOT BE IN TO
MEET OUR CLIMATE GOALS. WE NEED
TO FIND NEW AND CREATIVE WAYS TO
SUPPORT THE COMMERCIALIZATION
AND DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO CARBON
TECHNOLOGIES. THE LARGEST
SOURCES OF EMISSIONS IN THE
STATE TODAY COME FROM PASSENGER
VEHICLES. ACCELERATING THE
ADOPTION OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES IS THEREFORE CRITICAL.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA
FACES A HOUSING CRISIS AND THAT
BUILDING ALL ELECTRIC HOUSING IN
URBAN CENTERS WITH ACCESS TO
PUBLIC TRANSIT AND ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING. COULD HELP
REDUCE OUR RELIANCE ON PERSONAL
GASOLINE POWERED VEHICLES WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY ADDRESSING THE
HOUSING SHORTAGE. CALIFORNIANS
NEED BETTER ACCESS TO CLEAN AND
RELIABLE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
AND SAFE BIKING AND WALKING
CORRIDORS ALONG WITH ZERO CARBON
HOUSING OPTIONS. SECTOR BASED
SOLUTIONS LIKE THESE AND OTHER
COMPLEMENTARY POLICIES THAT
SUPPORT INCENTIVES AND FUNDING
FOR ACCELERATING THE CLEAN
ENERGY TRANSITION THAT IS
UNDERWAY WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
MAKE MORE RAPID PROGRESS TOWARDS
MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS. THE
PRIMARY CHALLENGE THAT I SEE IS
NOT A LACK OF AMBITION BUT A
QUESTION OF HOW WE WILL FINANCE
THESE NEEDED INVESTMENTS
EQUITABLY. AND RAPIDLY DEPLOY IN
ADOPTING NEW TECHNOLOGIES IN
EVERY SECTOR. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT OUR TWENTY TWENTY CARBON
NEUTRALITY STUDY THAT YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS
MAHONE. WHO WOULD LIKE TO START
. THIS FLOOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION TODAY
AND I THINK IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION AND
COMING FROM THE CENTRAL OUT
WHICH IS WHY I ASK THAT YOU
ALLOW ME TO BE ON THIS-
COMMITTEE- AS A- ELECTED FROM
STANISLAUS COUNTY SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY IN THE HEART OF THE AG
COMMUNITY. I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS- AND REALLY
SOMETIMES HAVE A RURAL
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE A LOT OF
WHAT WE'RE TALKING. ABOUT IS
KIND OF WAIT AROUND THE URBAN
SETTINGS. AND I THINK IT'S A
CONVERSATION THAT. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THAT WE UNDERSTAND THE
CRITICAL NATURE. OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND WHAT IT. PRODUCES FOR
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SO I DO HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
WHAT I WOULD LOVE- JUST RE KIND
OF TOUCH ON THEM AND ONE WAS
ABOUT CAP AND TRADE WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT I SUPPORT. AND
HAVE IN THE PAST SOMEONE TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT. AND THEN
KIND OF YOUR THOUGHTS ON. YOU
MENTIONED A COUPLE DIFFERENT
TIMES THAT DIFFERENT
TECHNOLOGIES- THEN JUST
ELECTRIFICATION. SO I GUESS MY
FIRST QUESTION IS- DO YOU
BELIEVE IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE TO FACILITATE AND
ENCOURAGE. THE USE OF CARBON
CAPTURING TECHNOLOGIES TO HELP
ACHIEVE OUR GHG REDUCTION GOALS%
. DO WE HAVE THE STATE PLAY A
ROLE IN THAT AS AS OF LIKE TO
BODY. YES THEY BELIEVE THAT IT
IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE ALL THE
TOOLS IN OUR TOOLBOX THERE WILL
NEED TO MEET THESE VERY
AMBITIOUS GOALS. AND CARBON
CAPTURE AND SEQUESTRATION IS ONE
OF THOSE TOOLS. THAT THAT NEEDS
SOME FURTHER. YOU KNOW. WE NEED
REGULATORY THAT SUPPORT TO
ENSURE THAT THE CARBON IS
CAPTURED AND SAFELY STORED. AND
BUT E ALSO NEED EFFORTS TO
FURTHER COMMERCIALIZE THIS
TECHNOLOGY THAT IS. IT IS NOT
WIDELY COMMERCIALIZED AND
DEPLOYED TODAY. RIGHT I THINK
I'M LOOKING AT YOU TO STREAM SO
I APOLOGIZE IF I'M LOOKING
SIDEWAYS AT YOU DON'T NEED TO BE
SO- AND THEN I SO APPRECIATE
THAT IN IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY-
IS. UNIQUELY POSITIONED WITHIN
THE STATE AS WELL. TO HELP
ACHIEVE SOME OF THOSE GOALS AND
THE NICE PART ABOUT THIS AS FAR
AS- STORAGE ON ON CAPTURING
CARBON. AND THE NICE PART ABOUT
OUR AREA AS WELL IS. IT PROVIDES
JOBS AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
ATRIAL S. A TRAINED SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE. AND SO FOR
THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT WOULD
THAT ARE IN THESE INDUSTRIES I
THINK IT IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
THAT WE CONTINUE TO STUDY THOSE.
REALLY UTILIZE THE GEOGRAPHICAL
LOCATION THE CENTRAL VALLEY AS
IT RELATES TO THE CARBON
CAPTURING AND THEN USE OUR-
SKILLED TRAINED WORKFORCE. TO DO
THAT- I MENTIONED BRIEFLY THAT I
WAS A SUPPORTER OF- CAP AND
TRADE WAS ONE OF THE FEW
REPUBLICANS THAT ACTUALLY
SUPPORTED THAT- SO THAT WAS A IT
WAS A GREAT EXPERIENCE. DO YOU
BELIEVE IT- IS A POINT WE TALK
ABOUT ACHIEVING THESE BROADER
GOALS POST TWENTY THIRTY BECAUSE
I WAS A CAP AND TRADE- EXPIRES
IN TWENTY THIRTY. THE WE ALSO
TALKED PULSE AND PRO LIKE TAP
INTO. THAT THAT WE CAN USE TO
MEET THE STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS
ONE OF THE BIG THINGS ABOUT CAP
AND TRADE AND REASON I SUPPORTED
IT. WAS BECAUSE OF INDUSTRIES
INVOLVEMENT IN THAT. IF WE JUST
COMPLETELY GO- OFF THE GRID OR
ELECTRIFICATION OVERNIGHT. THERE
IS GOING TO BE A TREMENDOUS COST
AND SO A STEP DOWN APPROACH- IS
CRITICAL AND I WOULD JUST LOVE.
YOUR COMMENTS. CAN WE STILL
ENCOURAGE INDUSTRIES TO ENGAGE
WITH ALL OF YOU TO HAVE THE STEP
DOWN APPROACH SO WE DON'T HAVE
JUSTICE MASSIVE INCREASE THE
COST OF LIVING- ACROSS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. I THINK YOU KNOW. I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHAT THE
QUESTION THERE IS CAP AND TRADE
IS BUT IT BEEN A VERY IMPORTANT
STRATEGY FOR RAISING FUNDS TO
SUPPORT OUR STATE'S CLIMATE
REDUCTION EFFORTS AND- I THINK
WHERE WE'RE GOING AND WE'RE
STILL GOING TO NEED INCREASED
AMBITION. IN THE INDUSTRIAL
SECTOR FOR DECARBONISATION AND
WHETHER CAP AND TRADE IS THE
ONLY MECHANISM THAT WE USED TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM THE
INDUSTRIAL SECTOR- I THINK. I
THINK THERE'S A QUESTION THAT I
HAVE THEIR AROUND WHETHER THAT
WILL BE ENOUGH IF OUR GOAL IS
TRULY DEAD CHIEF CARBON
NEUTRALITY. I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS- WITH ALL OF YOU STILL BE
WILLING TO ENGAGE WITH
INDUSTRIES TO ACHIEVE THESE
GOALS ONE OF THE PROGRAMS WITHIN
CAP AND TRADE WAS THE TRUCK
REPLACEMENT PROGRAM WHERE WE
TOOK TEARS ZERO ENGINES OUT AND
WE'RE UP TO NOW TIER FIVE. AND
WE WORKED WITH THE INDUSTRIES
WITH THE MANUFACTURERS WITH THE
DEALERSHIPS ACROSS THE STATE AND
THEIR SALES MEN AND WOMEN TO
DEVELOP A PROGRAM THAT THE AG
COMMUNITY BOUGHT INTO. IT BECAME
ONE OF THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAMS THE CARP HAS KIND OF
BEEN A PART OF FOR A VERY LONG
TIME AND THE COMMUNITY HAS
BOUGHT INTO US I THINK. IN GAUGE
MINT- AS OPPOSED TO THE MAT CARE
VERSUS THE STICK APPROACH IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THESE SECTORS ARE WILLING TO
MOVE. BUT AT A REASONABLE PACE.
SO WAS. I GUESS ARE WE STILL
WILL TO ENGAGE INDUSTRIES.
UNDERSTOOD I DON'T SPEAK FOR THE
EMERGENCIES- BUT I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT ENGAGEMENT IS A CRITICAL
STRATEGY FOR ACHIEVING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT AND I JUST
WANTED TO SAY AS WE MOVE FORWARD
IN THIS- COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA- IS A TREMENDOUS
CONCERN FOR MY COMMUNITY. AND
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKING AVIATION
TRAINS SHIPPING- RIGHT NOW.
THERE IS NOT A ELECTRIC TRACTOR
OUT THERE AND WE CURRENTLY ARE
THE BREAD BASKET OF THE WORLD WE
GROW THE SAFEST CLEANEST
PRODUCTS WE FEED AN ENTIRE
NATION LARGELY AND WE SHIP A LOT
OF EXPORTS INTO THE REST OF THE
WORLD. SO AS WE MOVE FORWARD I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE ALL OF US
TO BE VERY VERY COGNIZANT OF
THAT LIKE IF WE GO TO A
RECTIFICATION INSTANTLY THERE IS
GOING TO BE A TREMENDOUS COST
BECAUSE AT THIS POINT AND SOME
OF YOUR REPORTING LIVE ON PAGE
ELEVEN OF THE REPORT. THE
TECHNOLOGIES DON'T EVEN EXIST
YET WE HAVEN'T GOT THERE YET SO
WE HAVE TO BE VERY COGNISANT OF
THAT AND I WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE
ALL OF US TO KEEP THAT IN MIND
AS WE MOVE FORWARD THERE IS A
REAL IMPACT- TO THE MEN AND
WOMEN THAT LIVE IN MY COMMUNITY-
IN THE COST OF LIVING AND AT
SOME POINT- WE HAVE TO BE- JUST.
PROMISE OF THAT SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I WOULD AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS AS WELL. THANK YOU
CENTER BACKER. THANK YOU. OKAY
SO MY COMMENTS FOR THE NEXT THAT
PANEL. AS WELL BUT- I JUST IN
YOUR SOME SINS WHAT WERE THE
HARDEST- EMISSIONS TO ELIMINATE. THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION I'M-
WE SEE THE THERE ARE CHALLENGES
IN EVERY SECTOR AND OFTEN
GETTING THAT LAST 10% OF CARBON
OUT OF ANY SECTOR BECOMES
CHALLENGING- THAT SAID YOU KNOW
THINKING ABOUT SPECIFIC SECTORS.
WE SEE PARTICULAR CHALLENGES IN
FULLY ABATING EMISSIONS FROM
AVIATION. AT AND FROM OTHER OFF
ROAD TRANSPORTATION- INCLUDING
HEAVY DUTY SHIPPING. HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKING IS ANOTHER AREA WHERE
FURTHER COMMERCIALIZATION I IS
NEEDED- I TEMPERATURE INDUSTRIAL
PROCESS THESE MAY REQUIRE THINGS
LIKE HYDROGEN WHICH IS THE
AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY BUT AGAIN
NOT WIDELY COMMERCIALIZED- AND
THEN OF COURSE FULLY ELIMINATING
. CARBON EMISSIONS FROM THE
ELECTRICITY SECTOR GETTING THAT
LAST 10% WILL ALSO REQUIRE
DEVELOPMENTS IN NEW TECHNOLOGIES
THAT ARE NOT AVAILABLE TODAY TO
PROVIDE FIRMS ARE CARBON
CAPACITY. SO THERE'S CHALLENGES
IN EACH SECTOR AS YOU GET ALL
THE WAY OUT CLOSER TO ZERO-
ANYTHING ABOUT SCENARIOS THAT
CAN GET AS SOON AS YOU'RE A
FASTER YOU WHAT. WE USE BIGGEST
CONSTRAINTS FOR. BAD GETTING
THERE FASTER IS IT. BILL RATES
OF CLEAN ENERGY IS A
TRANSMISSION IS IT REPLACEMENT
CYCLES FOR VEHICLES AND SUCH
WHAT WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE
BIGGEST- THEY ARE. CONSTRAINED
THAT THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION-
IT'S ALL ALL OF THOSE- I DO SEE
THE REPLACEMENT CYCLE FOR
EQUIPMENT INCLUDING VEHICLES AND
TRUCKS AS BEING A CONSTRAINT
BECAUSE IT IS VERY EXPENSIVE TO.
PULL THOSE VEHICLES OFF THE ROAD
EARLY WHEN THEY'RE STILL BEING
USED AND USEFUL THAT'S QUITE
EXPENSIVE- BUT YOU KNOW THERE'S
- AN- PIECE OF INFRASTRUCTURE
BUILD REQUIRED TO ACHIEVE THE
ZERO CARBON ELECTRICITY GOALS-
THAT ALSO WE DON'T REQUIRES
BUILDING NEW TRANSMISSION
BUILDING ZERO CARBON RENEWABLE
CAPACITY- SO. THERE THERE IS A
IT WE CALL IT SOMETIMES
INFRASTRUCTURE INERTIA. IT'S
JUST THAT IT THE TIMING
CHALLENGE IN HOW QUICKLY THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN BE BUILT- IN
IN EACH SECTOR. THANKS IS A
FINALLY AND SO. YOU'RE REMEMBER
YOUR MOST AGGRESSIVE NERI THIS
BOUT IS IT THIRTY THREE MILLION
MEGATONS OF NEGATIVE EMISSIONS
IS THAT THE THAT'S YEAH THAT WAS
OUR- MOST AGGRESSIVE SCENARIO
THAT ELIMINATED FOSSIL FUEL
COMBUSTION BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
THE ZERO CARBON ENERGY SCENARIO
- AND WHAT I'M FOR YOUR MIND
WHAT ARE SOME EXAMPLES OF WHAT
CAN COULD BE COUNTED AS NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS. YEAH SO. THERE'S A
RANGE OF CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL
STRATEGIES- THE MOST WIDELY
COMMERCIALIZED TODAY IS DIRECT
AIR CAPTURE OF CO TWO FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE. BUT THERE'S ALSO YOU
KNOW LESS THAN ONE MILLION
METRIC TON OF DIRECT AIR CAPTURE
DEPLOYED GLOBALLY TODAY. SO
RELYING ENTIRELY ON THAT
STRATEGY SEEMS RISKY AND
CHALLENGING. IT ALSO REQUIRES A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF ENERGY TO
POWER DIRECTOR CAPTURE SO IT'S
NOT WITHOUT ITS OWN CHALLENGES.
THERE ARE OTHER TYPES OF CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL STRATEGIES
INCLUDING THE POTENTIAL TO
SEQUESTER CARBON IN NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS BUT AS YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S AT STRUGGLING WITH
WILDFIRES AND CLIMATE CHANGE AND
SO. YOU KNOW USING OUR NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS IS A CARBON
SINK AT IS IT A CHALLENGE ONTO
ITSELF. THERE'S OTHER AND MORE
SPECULATIVE FORMS OF CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL SUCH AS THINGS
LIKE ENHANCED WEATHERIZATION-
BUT SAID. I THINK AT SCALE
DIRECT AIR CAPTURE IS THE MOST
LIKELY SOLUTION IN THE NEAR TERM
. OKAY GREAT THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND JUST GIVE IT UP BECAUSE WE
HAD PREVIOUSLY MET HOW CONFIDENT
CAN WE BE THAT THESE NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS. ARE BECOMING
PERMANENT AN ADDITIONAL. BECAUSE
WE THERE'S BEEN CONCERNS ABOUT
OTHER OFFSETS THAT HAVE NOT.
BEEN PERMITTED AN ADDITIONAL.
YEAH I THINK THAT'S AN EXCELLENT
CONCERN AND WHEN ONE THAT WILL
NEED TO BE CAREFULLY MONITORED
AND EVALUATED- THE BENEFIT OF
DIRECT AIR CAPTURE IS THAT YOU
CAN MEASURE THE CARBON DIOXIDE
THAT IS BEING CAPTURED AND WHERE
THAT CO TWO IS BEING SEQUESTERED
. BUT IF IT'S IF THERE IS NO
REGULATIONS AND COMPLIANCE
MECHANISMS IN PLACE I WOULD ALSO
BE CONCERNED ABOUT ABOUT THE
ADDITIONALITY STYLE- I THINK
THAT THE- THAT THE POLICIES NEED
TO BE IN PLACE TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE NEGATIVE EMISSIONS- ARE
ARE PERMANENT AS PERMANENCE CAN
BE. THANK YOU. I THE MINISTER
GARCIA THANK IS CHAIR I'M
INTERESTED IN- EXTENDING A BIT
OF THE CONVERSATION THAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM CENTRAL VALLEY IS
PUT FORWARD- SPECIFICALLY TO
CARBON CAPTURE TECHNOLOGY YOU
MENTIONED WHAT'S MISSING RIGHT
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO PROVE THE
COMMERCIALIZATION OF THE
TECHNOLOGY WE HERE. IN THE
BUILDING QUITE OFTEN AND I REFER
TO IT AS SOME KIND OF THE- THE
FLAVOR OF THE DAY YOU KNOW AND
RIGHT NOW AND THE TECHNOLOGY
CONVERSATIONS AROUND RENEWABLE-
TECHNOLOGIES IT'S THE CARBON
CAPTURING TECHNOLOGIES AT WHAT
IS THE FRAMEWORK- THE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK THAT YOU BELIEVE- IS
STILL NOT- IN PLACE. TO BE ABLE
TO THEN GET TO THE LEVEL OF-
PROOF WHEN IT COMES TO.
COMMERCIALIZATION BECAUSE WE'RE
HEARING A LOT OF. A LOT OF
PEOPLE. LEANING ON THIS
TECHNOLOGY AND THE ABILITY TO
HELP WITH THE JUST TRANSITION
OF- MANY MANY JOBS THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS IN PLACE-
TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT- WE
CAN. GET TO OUR OUR GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES- MUCH QUICKER WITHOUT
A- MAJOR DISPLACEMENT OF PEOPLE
WORKING IN CURRENT. INDUSTRIES
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO SLOWLY
PHASE OUT SO MAYBE YOU CAN SHARE
WITH US YOUR THOUGHTS ON. WHAT
IS A REGULATORY FRAMEWORK LOOK
LIKE THEY NEED TO BE IN PLACE IN
ORDER TO DEMONSTRATE THE
SCALABILITY OF THIS TECHNOLOGY.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION- AND I
WILL NOT PRETEND TO BE AN EXPERT
ON REGULATION OF CARBON CAPTURE
AND SEQUESTRATION- BUT I WOULD.
SUGGEST THAT. THERE NEEDS TO BE
A MEASUREMENT. MONITORING AND
VERIFICATION PROTOCOL.
ASSOCIATED WITH CARBON CAPTURE
AND SEQUESTRATION- TO ENSURE
THAT AS THE CARBON STAYS
UNDERGROUND AND HI THIS IS-
SAFELY UNDERGROUND. ARE THERE
ANY- ASSESSMENTS OF WHAT- COULD
BE THE EXTENT OF. THE STATE
GOVERNMENT'S ROLE IN INVESTING
IN THOSE EFFORTS- WHAT IS MAYBE
TOO MUCH TO INVEST IN SOME NEW
TECHNOLOGY LIKE THIS- YEAH THE
TYPE OF INCENTIVES THAT- ARE
ASKED TO FROM US TO BE PUT
FORWARD WHEN IT COMES TO NEW
TECHNOLOGIES LIKE. SOLAR AND
WIND MANY YEARS AGO- TO BRING IT
TO POINT WHERE IT'S NOW- TOUTED
THAT IT IS AFFORDABLE TO DO I
MEAN I'M WONDERING DO YOU HAVE
ANY THOUGHTS ON ON THAT IN TERMS
OF THE FISCAL- ELEMENTS ARE
INVESTMENTS ON ON STATE
GOVERNMENT SIDE. TO TECHNOLOGY
LIKE THIS. WELL I DO KNOW THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH
THE FORTY FIVE Q. TAX CREDITS IS
ALREADY COMMITTED. A SIGNIFICANT
INCENTIVE TOWARDS CARBON CAPTURE
AND SEQUESTRATION. SO. IN TERMS
OF ADDITIONAL STATE SUPPORT- I'M
NOT SURE THAT. ADDITIONAL TAX
CREDITS WOULD BE NEEDED FOR CCS
SPECIFICALLY. MY PERSONAL VIEW
MIGHT BE TO FOCUS THOSE DOLLARS
ON- ON OTHER SECTORS GIVEN THAT
THE FEDERAL TAX INCENTIVES ARE
ALREADY IN PLACE FOR CCS. WE
APPRECIATE BOTH OF YOUR PERSONAL
VIEW GIVEN THAT YOU DO HAVE SOME
EXPERTISE IN THE WORK THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND ALSO JUST TO
THE OVERALL OF UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ALSO THANK YOU FOR
SHARING THAT- MIGHT MY NEXT SET
OF QUESTIONS WILL BE AROUND THE
IDEA THAT WE CONSTANTLY TALK
ABOUT. WE NEED A MIXED BAG OF
TOOLS- IN ORDER TO GET TO OUR
OBJECTIVES RIGHT BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO HAVING SOME OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS WHERE B. LET'S
TALK ABOUT HYDROGEN LET'S TALK
ABOUT SOME FOLKS AND OF OUR
COLLEAGUES ONE TALK ABOUT- AT
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS OTHER
FOLKS WANT TO TALK ABOUT. OTHER
TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX- BUT THEN
WE GET STUCK ON THE IDEA OF
ELECTRIFICATION- WHICH I AM A
100% IN FAVOR OF FOR A LOT OF
REASONS INCLUDING THE-
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT SURROUND THE
REGION THAT I REPRESENT WITH
LITHIUM I RECOVERY- BEING FRONT
AND CENTER OF A LOT OF
DISCUSSIONS NATIONALLY. AND HERE
IN OUR STATE BUT I ALSO SEE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY- HIT SOME
LOW HANGING FRUIT- WHEN IT COMES
TO IMPROVING AIR QUALITY IN
EMISSION REDUCTIONS USING THE
DIFFERENT TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX
BUT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT-
OCCASIONALLY WHEN THESE
CONVERSATIONS COME UP TO GET
SOME OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL.
FRIENDS TO AGREE. THAT THAT WE
COULD USE- HYDROGEN SOME CASES
THAT IN SOME PLACES THAT MIGHT
WORK- TO MOVE IN THE DIRECTION
OF RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS AND
I'M- SHARING WITH YOU
PERSPECTIVES THAT ARE DIVERSE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY CONVERSATIONS
AND SO THAT'S REALLY NOT MY
SPECIFIC VIEWS ITSELF BUT I'M
TRYING TO REFLECT THE- A
CONVERSATION THAT ARE HAPPY THAT
THAT'S HAPPENING AMONGST OUR OUR
COLLEAGUES. HOW DO WE SET. THE
TONE. THAT WE HAVE TO. HAVE A
DIVERSE PORTFOLIO IN ORDER TO
ACHIEVE THESE GOALS AND NOT GET
STUCK ON ONE PARTICULAR- LANE.
AND PATHWAY BECAUSE I THINK THAT
HAPPENS QUITE OFTEN- WITH US
HERE IN- THE LEGISLATURE. I HAVE
WHO WANT TO INVEST THE MONIES
AND OTHER TECHNOLOGIES WE'RE
BEING TOLD WERE TAKEN AWAY FROM.
FROM ELECTRIFICATION GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AND SO YOUR THOUGHTS-
YOUR POSITION ORGANIZATION
ANALYSIS ON ANY OF THAT IS
THERE. A ORDER OF HOW WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE WITH THE
VARIOUS. TOOLS IN THE TOOLBOX AS
IT'S OFTEN SAID. I THINK IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION. AND YOU KNOW
HISTORICALLY I'VE BEEN A FAN OF
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL POLICY
SOLUTIONS THAT LEAVE ROOM FOR
THE FACT THAT THERE'S INNOVATION
AND UNKNOWNS IN HOW TECHNOLOGY
WILL DEVELOP. ON THAT SAID INNER
ENERGY SYSTEMS MODELING WE TEND
TO FIND SOME FAIRLY CONSISTENT
THEMES WHEN LOOKING AT LEAST
COST OR LOWER COST SOLUTIONS TO
DECARBONIZE THE ECONOMY. AND AT
THAT THAT TENDS TO BE DERIVED
FROM SORT OF JUST THE
FUNDAMENTAL- ENERGY REQUIREMENTS
FOR DIFFERENT DECARBONISATION
SOLUTIONS SO FOR EXAMPLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S RELATIVELY MILD
CLIMATE WE DO FIND THAT ELECTRIC
AIR SOURCE HEAT PUMPS ARE VERY
EFFICIENT. SOLUTION FOR
DECARBONISING LOW TEMPERATURE
HEAT NEEDS LIKE SPACE HEATING
AND WATER HEATING- FOR THE-
MAJORITY OF CUSTOMERS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WILL BE AN
EFFECTIVE SOLUTION NO WE DON'T
FIND THAT TO BE- AS CLEAR OF A
SOLUTION IN COLDER CLIMATES- SO
YOU KNOW. NORTHERN HIGHLAND
ASIAN PARTS OF CALIFORNIA YOU
MAY STILL NEED TO CARBONIZED
FUELS AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY THAT ARE COLDER WILL
LIKELY STILL NEED DECARBONISE
FEELS TO ME. WINTER PEAK HEATING
NEEDS IN IN VERY COLD CLIMATES.
SO YOU KNOW THAT'S THE SORT OF
ONE EXAMPLE OF THE KIND OF MERIT
ORDER OF DECARBONISATION
SOLUTIONS THAT THEY DO VARY. BY
SECTOR- BUT THESE ARE YOU KNOW
THESE ARE. TRADEOFFS THAT
INVOLVE- A RANGE OF
CONSIDERATIONS NOT JUST ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND COST BUT ALSO. IN
CUSTOMER CHOICES WHAT ARE YOU
REALISTIC. RETROFIT SOLUTIONS
FOR EXISTING BUILDINGS AND
INDUSTRY- SO I THINK IT IS VERY
HARD TO. CHOOSE A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL SOLUTION FOR EVERY.
APPLICATION AND THAT'S THAT'S
WHERE I DO THINK THAT HAVING.
CERTAIN THAT. TECHNOLOGY
AGNOSTIC SOLUTIONS CAN BE
BENEFICIAL THANK YOU FOR THAT
ANSWER RIGHT I YEAH I AGREE- AND
YOU KNOW THERE'S A FEW THINGS
THAT WE TAKE AWAY FROM YOUR
RESPONSE IN ONE OF A MIGHT I'M
THINKING IS- D. REGION. RIGHT
THAT KIND OF CAN ALSO DETERMINE
THE TYPE OF TECHNOLOGIES- THAT-
YOU INCORPORATE GIVEN THE
CHANGES IN IN CLIMATE THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING ARM. AND THE OTHER
IS- I WANT TO JUST SAY THAT IT
WITH THE BEST FIT LOW COST
BENEFIT MODEL ARE THAT WE'VE
UTILIZED OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
HAS REALLY PUT US IN A PLACE
WHERE WE'RE STILL TALKING ABOUT-
THE LACK OF ENERGY RELIABILITY.
RIGHT THAT WE HAVE TOO MUCH OF
ONE- THAT TECHNOLOGY IS NOT NOT
THE OTHER AND ARE EXPERIENCING
THE WHAT THE FAMOUS A LITTLE
CURVE THAT WE SEE ON ON
DOCUMENTS THAT WE TALK ABOUT AS
THAT THE DOCTOR. AND NOT HAVING
THE ENERGY RELIABILITY TO KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON AND IN THAT THE
APPROACH THERE HAS BEEN NO COST
BEST FIT- AND SO I'M HOPEFUL
THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE TRULY
TAKE A LOOK AT. THE LESSONS
LEARNED THERE FOR PURPOSES OF
GREATER. ENERGY RELIABILITY ALL
I'M GONNA MAKE JUST ONE LAST.
JOIN IN AND WANTED TO JUST
PLANT. THE CONVERSATION HERE WE
WE'RE PRIVILEGED ENOUGH TO CHAIR
THE UTILITIES AND ENERGY
COMMITTEE WHAT WE WANT TO SPEND
QUITE A BIT OF TIME ON. THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT TRANSMISSION
. AND BECAUSE WITHOUT THE
COMPONENT OF CONVENIENCE AND
THEN TRANSITION- BUILD OUT- AND
TODAY I BELIEVE. AND YOU MAY
AGREE OR NOT BUT THAT- WE ARE
NOT IN LINE TO MEET OUR
RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS. AND
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS FOR A
LOT OF REASONS AND ONE OF THEM
HAS TO DO WITH. HOW LONG IT
TAKES TO SITE- PERMIT AND BUILD
A TRANSMISSION AND AS WE TALK
ABOUT ALL OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES
INCLUDING CARBON. CAPTURE AND
SEQUESTRATION- YOU KNOW THE LAST
TRANSMISSION PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA IT'S MY UNDERSTAND
TOOK NINE YEARS TO SITE AND
PERMIT- WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET
THERE RIGHT AND SO I'M HOPING
THAT WE CAN. HAVE A
CONVERSATION. WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND OTHER RELEVANT
COMMITTEES AS IT RELATES TO WHAT
WE CAN DO. BETTER WHEN IT COMES
TO SITING AND PERMITTING
TRANSMISSION FOR A MEETING OUR-
CLIMATE AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
OBJECTIVES AND- WONDER IF YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT. AND
THAT WOULD BE MY LAST QUESTION
AND COMMENT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR MOMMY TO A CHIME IN IN
THIS VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION.
THANK YOU AND THEY DO HAVE A
COMMENT THERE WHICH IS THAT. A
LOT OF OUR WORK IT EATERY HAS.
ILLUSTRATED THE VALUE OF A BROAD
REGIONAL GRID IN ACHIEVING OUR
DECARBONISATION GOALS RELIABLY
AND COST EFFECTIVELY. AND
BUILDING NEW TRANSMISSION. TO
INTERCONNECT THOSE RENEWABLE
RESOURCES INTO CALIFORNIA. IS
ESSENTIAL AND IT IT DOES.
CURRENTLY TAKE SOMETHING LIKE
TEN YEARS DEPARTMENT A LARGE NEW
TRANSMISSION LINE. WHICH IS
PROBABLY SLOWER THAN WE WOULD
LIKE IF WE WANT TO ACCELERATE
OUR CLIMATE GOALS. THANK YOU
WANT TO WELCOME THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CLAUDIO OUR NEWEST MEMBER
TO. OF THIS JOINT COMMITTEE-
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER- DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS- AND AT THIS
TIME. SENATE SKINNER HERE OKAY
OKAY. ALL RIGHT I HAVE SOME.
QUESTIONS I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MS MAHONEY- I'VE BEEN. FOCUSED
ON YOUR STUDY- AT LEAST FOR THE
LAST TWO YEARS AND- AND SO IT'S
GREAT TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
- I DO A DIVE MORE INTO YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY REPORT- CHIEF IN
CARBON NEUTRALITY IN IN
CALIFORNIA FIRST OF ALL. MMHM
BUT YOUR YOUR OCTOBER TWENTY
TWENTY REPORT- TO. IT DID DO YOU
STILL STAND BY THE REPORT I KNOW
YOU CONTINUE TO BE WORKING WITH
THE A. R. B. AS AS THEY ARE
DEVELOPING THE SCOPING PLAN BUT-
YOU KNOW BY AND LARGE THE THAT
THE FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
OF YOUR TWENTY TWENTY REPORT-
YOU YOU STILL STAND BY THEM AS
FAR AS YOUR WORK WITH A P.
THAT'S RIGHT. YEP THERE WAS A-
HIGHER LEVEL STUDY THAN WHAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY UNDERTAKING SO I
THINK WE'LL HAVE A LOT OF. NEW
INSIGHTS- IT'S MORE DETAILED
WORK. BUT THE HIGH LEVEL FINDING
STILL STAND OKAY. SO I KNOW THAT
IN YOUR REPORT. YOU FOCUS ON ON
ON THREE. ACT WAYS- YEAR- HI.
CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL SCENARIO
YOUR ZERO CARBON ENERGY SCENARIO
AND YOUR BALANCE SCENARIO WHERE-
I BELIEVE. IT RANGES IN TERMS OF
THE EMISSION REDUCTIONS AND
GROWTH'S GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS- FROM 92% REDUCTION.
BY. 2045287% REDUCTION BEING THE
BALLOT SCENARIO AND THE- AND THE
THIRD SCENARIO THE PET THIRD
PATHWAY BEING 80% REDUCTION IN
GROSS GREAT GHG EMISSIONS. ARM
FIRST OF A CLARIFICATION THE
THESE ALL THREE OF THESE
SCENARIOS- ARE TALKING ABOUT
REDUCTIONS AND GROSS GHG
EMISSIONS THAT DOES NOT INCLUDE-
CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL AS PART
OF THOSE PERCENTAGES IS DYING IS
THAT CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT
OKAY SIR SO THE IDEA IS THAT THE
CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL WOULD
ADDRESS THE REMAINING PERCENTAGE
IN ORDER TO GET TO THE HUNDRED
PERCENT- CARBON NEUTRALITY BY
BEFORE TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
EXACTLY OKAY. SO- SO I A I GUESS
. YOU KNOW THERE THERE WERE
THERE WAS A BILL ON ON THE ON ON
THIS LAST YEAR THAT THAT THAT
STILL KICKING AROUND BUT- IT'S A
- YOU KNOW THE QUESTION THAT WAS
ON THE THAT I'VE HEARD OFTEN- IS
HOW REALISTIC IS IT THAT WE CAN
GET TO YOU KNOW 90% REDUCTION IN
GROSS HG 87% 80% I MEAN. YOU
KNOW WE N. N. N. ARE LINED LINE
OF WORK IT'S OFTEN EASIER TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO
IT'S HARD TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
GET THERE I WANT TO SEE IF YOU
CAN OPINE ON HOW REALISTIC IT IS
TO GET TO THESE- J. SHE
REDUCTION GOALS. WELL IT'S
REALISTIC FROM A TECHNOLOGY.
FIVE AND ENERGY SYSTEMS
PERSPECTIVE. BUT IT'S UNKNOWN
HOW REALISTIC IT WOULD BE FROM
AN ACTUAL IMPLEMENTATION
CONSUMER ADOPTION- POINT OF VIEW
BECAUSE WE DON'T YET HAVE THE
POLICIES IN PLACE THAT WOULD
ACCOMPLISH THAT GOAL. IF THAT
ANSWERS YOUR QUESTION- IT
BASICALLY WE KNOW THAT WE CAN DO
IT IF WE CAN DEPLOY THE
TECHNOLOGY. AT THE PACE THAT WE
ASSUMED. IN THE MODEL BUT THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU GET THE
DEPLOYMENT. HER AT THE PACE OF
THE ASSUMED IN THE MODEL AND YOU
KNOW THE MODEL CAN'T ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. OKAY SO IT IS SO IN
OTHER WORDS I'M DID THAT THREE
PATHWAYS THE THREE SCENARIOS AT
THE SET FORTH IN YOUR REPORT ME
THAT DID THOSE ARE. THOSE ARE
ROAD MAPS BUT BUT THEN IT'S- UP
TO THE REST OF US TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO MAKE IT WORK. YEAH THAT'S
RIGHT I WOULD SAY WHAT WE'RE
DOING I CALL IT A BACK THING
EXERCISE SO WE'RE STARTING FROM
THE END GOAL IN MIND WHICH IN
THIS CASE IT WAS CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
AND THEN ANSWERING THE QUESTION
WHAT WOULD HAVE NEEDED TO HAPPEN
BY WHEN IN ORDER TO GET US
THERE. AND SO IT GIVES US SOME
YOU KNOW ILLUSTRATIVE I BY POSTS
FOR EACH SECTOR OF THE THINGS
THAT NEED TO HAVE HAPPENED IN
TERMS OF SALES OF ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES DEPLOYMENT OF.
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY IN TERMS
OF TOTAL MEGAWATTS OF CAPACITY.
YEAH I THINK THOSE ARE USEFUL
DATA POINTS. BUT IT STILL
DOESN'T ANSWER THE QUESTION OF
YOU KNOW WHERE'S THE FUNDING
COMING FROM- AND WHAT'S THE
POLICY MECHANISM TO ENABLE AND-
FOR REQUIRE THAT LEVEL OF
TECHNOLOGY DEPLOYMENT. ALL RIGHT
. SO I WAS ON A CONFERENCE
RECENTLY AND- THERE WERE THERE
WAS A PERSPECTIVE OFFERED THAT-
THAT THE- YOU KNOW DID IT DID
THE PROBLEM WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
IS NOT WITH FOSSIL FUELS THE
PROBLEM IS WITH THE CO TWO- YOU
KNOW SUGGESTING THAT THAT- IN A
WAY IF. YOU KNOW THIS WONDERFUL
TECHNOLOGY OF CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE CARBON CAPTURE
UTILIZATION AND STORAGE WAY
WHATEVER YOU. CHOOSE TO. TO CALL
IT- IF THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO-
YOU KNOW RELY HEAVILY ON FOSSIL
FUELS YOU KNOW. IF WE UTILIZE
THESE THE WONDERFUL NEW
INNOVATIONS IN THE AREA OF
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE WE
WHAT WHAT IS YOUR OPINION ON ON
THAT POSITION. THAT SOUNDS LIKE
A GROSS OVERSIMPLIFICATION TO ME
FIRST OF ALL WE KNOW THAT THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN THE STATE AND
THAT'S BECAUSE OF FOSSIL FUEL
EMISSIONS AND WE- THAT.
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IS AN
IMPORTANT STRATEGY TO REDUCE
THOSE EMISSIONS. LIKE I SAID I
DO SUPPORT CARBON CAPTURE AND
SEQUESTRATION IS ONE OF THE
TOOLS IN OUR TOOLBOX. BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT. WERE LEADING
FOSSIL FUELS OFF THE HOOK
ENTIRELY. IT IS THE CCS IS
LIKELY TO PLAY. YOU KNOW A SMALL
TARGETED STRATEGIC ROLE IN
REDUCING EMISSIONS FROM
OTHERWISE HARD TO ABATE SECTORS
. BUT IT'S NOT A PANACEA. AND SO
GOING BACK TO THE PERCENTAGES
THAT WE STARTED TALKING ABOUT-
IT'S COMPARED TO THE- THE THAT
90% 92% REDUCTION IN IMPORT SAY
90% IN- REDUCTION AND SHE SHE
EMISSIONS OF NECESSARY. YOU'RE
ENVISIONING YOU KNOW CARBON-
DIOXIDE REMOVAL TECHNOLOGIES- AS
WELL AS NATURAL WORKING LAND.
THAT YOU KNOW APPROACH TO TAKE
THA REMAINING PERCENTAGE
BETWEEN 8% 220% OF THE NECESSARY
REDUCTION TO REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY. WELL IT IT MAY WE
MAY NOT EVEN NEED MORE CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL TECHNOLOGIES
THAN THAT YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY
THAT DEATH THREE SCENARIOS THAT
WE EVALUATED IN THIS TWENTY
TWENTY STUDY WERE VERY AMBITIOUS
IN TERMS OF ASSUMING AS
REDUCTIONS IN FOSSIL FUELS. THAT
HAPPENED YOU KNOW MORE QUICKLY
THAN WE'VE EVER SEEN
HISTORICALLY- AND SO. EVEN YOU
KNOW WHETHER WE CAN ACCOMPLISH
THAT IS I THINK STILL AN OPEN
QUESTION AND WE MAY NEED EVEN
MORE AT. CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL
WE- IF WE CAN'T REDUCE OUR
DIRECT GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
THAT AS QUICKLY AS WE WOULD LIKE
. SO LOOKING TO BE A CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL STRATEGIES AND
YOU YOU TALK IN YOUR REPORT
ABOUT. AW YOU KNOW RELIANCE ON
QUOTE RELATIVELY UNTESTED CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL STRATEGIES AND
STRATEGIES WHICH ARE NOT A WIDE
WIDELY COMMERCIALIZED I MEAN.
THE IT IS IT IS IT FAIR TO SAY
WHAT WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW
THE MOST COMMERCIALLY AVAILABLE
AND SCALABLE- CARBON DIOXIDE-
REMOVALS- OPTION THAT WE HAVE
NOW IS DIRECT AIR CAPTURE THAT
IT'S STILL. IS IN ITS INFANCY
HIS IT IS AT A- IS THAT YOUR
POSITION. THIRD STRAIGHT CARBON
DIOXIDE REMOVAL- AND DIRECT AIR
CAPTURE HAS BEEN DEMONSTRATED
THERE'S A FEW OPERATIONAL
FACILITIES GLOBALLY SO I DO
BELIEVE THAT IT IT CAN BE SCALED
UP BUT I DON'T KNOW HOW QUICKLY
AND IT IS STILL AS I MENTIONED
AN EXPENSIVE AND ENERGY
INTENSIVE PROCESS. SO THE GOAL
IN THE SCENARIOS THAT WE MODELED
IN TWENTY TWENTY WAS TO REDUCE
THE RELIANCE ON DIRECT AIR
CAPTURE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE. BUT
EVEN WITH THOSE VERY AMBITIOUS
ASSUMPTIONS WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
FIND A FEASIBLE WAY TO ELIMINATE
ALL DIRECT EMISSIONS FROM THE
STATE BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE. AND
SO THAT NECESSITATES SOME OTHER
SOLUTION AND WE WOULDWE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE A BETTER SOLUTION
THAN THAN RELYING ON ONE IT IS
NOT SO FULLY COMMERCIALIZED BUT-
THE REALITY IS THAT THERE THERE
IS NOT TODAY. AND I THINK THAT-
CONSIDERATION SHOULD FACTOR INTO
OUR DECISIONS ABOUT YOU KNOW
TIMING AS WELL BECAUSE IT WILL
TAKE TIME. TO COMMERCIALISE AND
SCALE THESE NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
ARM. THE POINT IS ALWAYS A IT
HAS AS OFTEN ALSO OFTEN BEEN
MADE THAT- THAT CALIFORNIA IS-
IS- YOU KNOW- ESTIMATED TO
CONTRIBUTE ABOUT 1% OF THE
WORLD'S- GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS- WHAT IS THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
MAKE- YOU KNOW GLOBALLY GIVEN
THAT WERE ONLY 1% OF OUR SHARE
OF THE GLOBAL GHG. EMISSION IT'S
A GREAT QUESTION. WELL I DO
BELIEVE CALIFORNIA SOMETHING
LIKE BETWEEN THE FIFTH AND THE
SEVENTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD AND SO WHAT WE DO TO
COMMERCIALIZE AND BRING DOWN THE
COST OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES. AND TO
DEMONSTRATE THE SCALABILITY OF
TECHNOLOGIES. IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE OF THIS YOU
LEADING. ROLE THAT WE PLAY IN
THE GLOBAL ECONOMY. ALL RIGHT I
THINK IT'S IN THAT LEADERSHIP
POSITION THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A
VERY IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY AND
SO THAT WOULD INCLUDE. YOU ARE-
IDENTIFYING CARBON CAPTURE
CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL
TECHNOLOGY- AS PART OF THAT
INNOVATION THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
CAN LEAD IN. YEAH I THINK SO
OKAY. LAST TO COME IN BEFORE I
TURN OVER TO THE CENTER SKINNER
AYE I KNOW THAT TO. ONE OF THE
MAIN. OBJECTIONS THAT WE GET TO-
ANY KIND OF CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE- DISCUSSION IS THE
CONCERN ESPECIALLY AND- LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OF- THE- FEAR THAT
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE WILL-
YOU KNOW. ENABLE THE COULD THEY
ARE OUR CONTINUED RELIANCE ON ON
FOSSIL FUELS TO THE DETRIMENT OF
THESE- ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE SUFFERED A
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF TOXIC
EMISSIONS AND CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS. OUR OUR OUR OUR
THEIR SIMILAR TECHNOLOGIES- UP
TO CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL IN
TERMS OF THE CAPTURE AND REMOVAL
OF TOXIC EMISSIONS AND CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS. THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION- THERE'S CERTAINLY AT
KNOX CONTROL TECHNOLOGIES AND
OTHER WAYS TO REDUCE POLLUTION-
WE'VE SEEN YOU KNOW ABATEMENT
FROM MERCURY FROM COAL PLANTS
FOR EXAMPLE SO. I WOULDN'T SAY
THAT IT'S THE SAME TECHNOLOGY AS
DIRECTOR CAPTURE BUT THERE ARE.
OPTIONS THERE. THEY DO. CAN CURB
THAT I COMMUNITIES SHOULD HAVE A
VOICE IN THAT TYPES OF
FACILITIES THAT ARE OPERATING IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS. SO I THINK
THAT'S A FAIR CRITIQUE I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DISTINGUISHING BETWEEN. DIRECT
AIR CAPTURE WHICH IS A NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS TECHNOLOGY AND CARBON
CAPTURE AND SEQUESTRATION WHICH
IS A WAY TO. ABATE POLLUTION
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE GO INTO THE
ATMOSPHERE SO THEY HAVE YOU KNOW
VERY DIFFERENT APPLICATIONS
COULD BE LOCATED IN VERY
DIFFERENT. PARTS OF THE OF THE
STATE. THERE'S ALSO. NO REASON
THAT DIRECT AIR CAPTURE ACTUALLY
NEEDS TO BE PHYSICALLY LOCATED
IN CALIFORNIA. I BECAUSE IT'S-
PULLING CARBON DIOXIDE OUT OF
THE ATMOSPHERE WHICH IS A GLOBAL
ABSOLUTE AND SO I THINK THAT'S
ANOTHER IMPORTANT THING TO KEEP
IN MIND. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SEVERAL SKINNER- THANK
YOU FIVE. SERVER SIXTEEN. I'M
YEAH I APPRECIATE THE- THE-
TERRACE CONNECTING INTERNET
MICHAEL THANK I HAD I HAD TURNED
IT ON IS IT NOT THE WAY I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU- INCLUDED IN
THE REPORT THE- SOME OPTIONS-
THE- THE NEED OR- POSSIBILITIES
FOR CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE
AND ARE BOTH I THINK YOU'RE BOTH
TECHNOLOGIES AS FAR AS I CAN
READ I READ THE REPORT. AND YET
YOU ALSO YOUR- CAUTIONARY ABOUT
THAT A MOMENT IT'S NOT WE DON'T
HAVE THE COMMERCIALIZATION THAT
WOULD PUT IT INTO A- A DOMINANT
STRATEGY THAT WE WOULD RELY ON
AND I THINK THE OTHER REASON
AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID SHE
KIND OF POINTED OUT THAT THE
OTHER REASON IT WOULD I THINK
BE- NOT WISE TO HAVE IT THE
DOMINANT IS BECAUSE- WE DO NOT
WANT TO USE. ANY OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES WHETHER FOR
DIRECTOR CAPTURE OR FOR THE
CAPTURE AND SEQUESTRATION. TO
SUBSTITUTE FOR EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS BUT RATHER- BECAUSE
OF THE RIVER IT EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS IN THE MOVING OFF OF
THE SOURCES THAT ARE CAUSING
EMISSIONS IS SO ESSENTIAL BUT
IT'S MORE RECOGNITION OF THAT
THE CRISIS IS SO REAL RIGHT NOW.
AND THE ACTIONS URGENT. AND
QUICKLY NEEDED TO ABATE THE
WORST DESTRUCTION THERE WE HAVE
TO HAVE ALL THE TOOLS IN THE ON
THE TABLE AND CLEARLY THE I. P.
C. REPORT. SEVEN STREETS THAT
LBNL DUE TO RECENT REPORT THAT
DEMONSTRATES THAT IT ALL
DEMONSTRATES THAT NOW. ON THE
QUESTION OF. THE I THE
COMMERCIALIZATION. IF WE TAKE
FOR EXAMPLE UTILITY GRADE
BATTERY STORAGE. AS FAR AS I
KNOW THERE WA NO UTILITY GRADE
BATTERY STORAGE. ONLINE IN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN I PASSED WHEN I
AUTHORED THE BILL. THAT I HAD
THE UC START THE- PROCEEDINGS TO
HAVE OUR UTILITIES PURCHASE I
REGRADED IN ENERGY STORAGE AND
NOT A MIND ACTUALLY I WANT TO
CORRECT THAT IT WAS TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL IN THE PURPOSE OF IT WAS
TO JUST RECOGNIZE THAT AS WE
MOVE TO- DECARBONIZE OUR
ELECTRICITY GO TO RENEWABLES WE
HAD TO HAVE SOME STORAGE WE HAVE
TO DO. SO AND WE WANTED TO LOOK
WHY SHOULD WE ALREADY PREDICT IN
ADVANCE WHAT TECHNOLOGY IS GOING
TO EMERGE LET'S JUST MAKE SURE
WE SEND MARKET SIGNALS TO HELP
INSURE THAT TECHNOLOGIES DO
EMERGE. CIRCUIT SENDS SIGNALS TO
GET THE ALREADY AND THE
COMMERCIALIZATION THAT'S
NECESSARY WE HAVE. PHENOMENALLY
ACHIEVE THAT PHENOMENALLY SO IT
IS SIMILAR. IN THAT WELL I CAN'T
GUARANTEE THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE IT
IN THIS OTHER AREA IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO SEND THOSE
SIGNALS AT THE SAME TIME. THAT
WE DON'T RENEGE ON OUR GOALS OF
THE OF MOVING OFF OF. THE
SOURCES SO WHEN I LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA'S POLICIES AND YOU
KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER FOR EXAMPLE OF. STOPPING
THE SALE OF COMBUSTION- VEHICLES
SPICER NEAR AND SUCH. THAT IS
CLEARLY INFORMING PEOPLE THAT WE
- IN OTHER WORDS THOSE KIND OF
POLICIES ALONG WITH SOME
POLICIES AROUND DIRECTOR CAPTURE
IN CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE. I
WOULD HOPE WOULD. HELP TO
AMELIORATE THESE CONCERNS THAT
WE WOULD BE DOING SO JUST TO GET
US TO RELY ON THOSE TECHNOLOGIES
NOW. MY QUESTION TO YOU IS WELL
YOU CAN'T. YOU INDICATED
YOURSELF YOU DON'T KNOW. I I'M
JUST MAYBE IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE
SPECULATION BUT- DO YOU FEEL
THAT A STATE LIKE CALIFORNIA
GIVEN OUR LEADERSHIP ROLE THAT
WERE THAT POLICIES IN THIS AREA
MIGHT. WHAT'S YOUR SENSE OF HOW
MUCH INFLUENCE YOU COULD HAVE ON
HELPING TO GET THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES BROUGHT. DEVELOPED
AND BROUGHT TO MARKET. WELL YEAH
AS I SAID CALIFORNIA IS A HUGE
PLAYER IN THE GLOBAL ENERGY
ECONOMY AND I DO THINK THAT- WE
CAN HELP TO COMMERCIALIZE AND
BRING DOWN THE COST OF REVENUE
AND EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES
ABSOLUTELY- AND YOU'RE YOU'RE
CORRECT SENATOR SKINNER AND THAT
I IT NONE OF OUR-
DECARBONISATION SCENARIOS. RELY
ON. A SINGLE STRATEGY- AND
CARBON CAPTURE AND SEQUESTRATION
IS OF RELATIVELY SMALL STRATEGY
COMPARED TO THE OTHER
DECARBONISATION SOLUTIONS THAT
ARE BEING DEPLOYED. BUT IT IS
STILL A CRITICAL STRATEGY TO
GETTING TO NET ZERO OR CARBON
NEUTRALITY. BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A
DAUNTING TASK AND REQUIRES AS A
WHOLE RANGE OF SOLUTIONS- IF
WE'RE GOING TO BE SUCCESSFUL. I
SEE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS I. HAVE
ONE LAST WRAP OF QUICK QUESTION
SO WHEN YOU SAY CRITICAL IN
TERMS OF CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE DID THEY HAVE YOU
IDENTIFIED ANY REALISTIC PATHWAY
FOR CALIFORNIA TO GET TO GET TO-
CARBON NEUTRALITY WITHOUT CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE. THE THAT'S
A GOOD QUESTION- I. I BELIEVE I
MEAN I BELIEVE THAT I. YOU COULD
PROBABLY STILL DO IT. BUT IT
WOULD REQUIRE- A RANGE OF YOU
KNOW ADDITIONAL EXPENSIVE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE ALSO NOT
WIDELY COMMERCIALIZED. ALL RIGHT
I DON'T SEE A REASON TO TAKE IT
OFF THE TABLE I WOULDN'T SAY
DEFINITIVELY THAT IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE WITH. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO VISIT MOUNT MAHONE-
FOR YOU FOR YOUR- YOUR TIME
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT HI I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE OR NOT- OTHER
PANELISTS PATIENTLY WAITING TO
BUT- OUR NEXT SPEAKER FOR OUR
FIRST PANEL IS ERIN MAYFIELD.
ASSISTANT PROFESSOR AT DARTMOUTH
COLLEGE'S THAYER SCHOOL OF
ENGINEERING. TO PRESENT
VIRTUALLY FONG- HER- NOW ZERO
AMERICA REPORT. A PROFESSOR
MAYFIELD. I SEE YOUR GRAPHICS
SHOWING ON OUR SCREEN. DO WE
HAVE YOU ON MIKE. LOOKING YES WE
CAN WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU SO THANK YOU FOR IT
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
INVITATION AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY ABOUT TO
CARBONIZED THINGS ECONOMY TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE I WILL TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THE NET
ZERO AMERICA PROJECT CARRIED OUT
BY A PRINCETON LED RESEARCH TEAM
THIS PROJECT EVALUATED
ALTERNATIVE PATHWAYS TO ACHIEVE
NET ZERO EMISSIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES BY MID CENTURY. AND WE
EVALUATED NOT ONLY THE TECHNICAL
AND COST ASPECTS BUT WHAT DO
THESE TRANSITIONS MEAN FOR
AMERICANS IN TERMS OF IMPACTS
SUCH AS ENERGY AFFORDABILITY
ENERGY SECURITY JOBS LAND USE
THEIR QUALITY. BY WAY OF MY
BACKGROUND. ALLEGE MY RESEARCH
IS IN THE AREAS OF SUSTAINABLE
SYSTEMS ENGINEERING AND PUBLIC
POLICY AND I CURRENTLY SERVE AS
AN AUTHOR ON THE FIFTH NATIONAL
CLIMATE ASSESSMENT. PRIOR TO
ACADEMIA I WORKED FOR SEVERAL
YEARS AS A PRACTITIONER WORKING
WITHIN IN OVERBURDEN AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES ON HAZARDOUS
WASTE REMEDIATION ENVIRONMENTAL
EDUCATION. AND INFRASTRUCTURE
PLANNING. SO I WILL GIVE A VERY
HIGH. LEVEL OVERVIEW OF
CALIFORNIA'S ROLE IN MEETING A
US WIDE NET ZERO EMISSIONS GOAL
. THIS SLIDE SHOWS ANNUAL
ELECTRIC POWER GENERATION IN
CALIFORNIA OUT TO TWENTY FIFTY
IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT YOU WAITED A
REFERENCE CASE WHICH ESSENTIALLY
ASSUME STATIC POLICIES IN
ADDITION TO ALTERNATIVE THAT
ZERO PATHWAYS. SO AS YOU CAN SEE
IN THE FOR NETZERO SCENARIOS
PRESENTED IN WE MODELED MANY
OTHER SCENARIOS AS WELL OUR
GENERATION EIGHTEEN INCREASES TO
MEET INCREASING ELECTRICITY
DEMAND RESULTING FROM THE
ELECTRIFICATION OF
TRANSPORTATION. RESIDENTIAL AND
COMMERCIAL BUILDINGS AND BEING
IN POSSESSION OF PROPERTIES. YOU
CAN SEE THAT THE FIRST TEN YEARS
OF THE TRANSITION ARE SIMILAR
ACROSS ILLNESS IT'S ZERO
SCENARIOS WITH ISSUE MAKING USE
OF NATURAL GAS AND INCREASING
RENEWABLES ESPECIALLY SOLAR. AND
BY TWENTY THIRTY AND EVEN MORE
SAVES SO BY TWENTY OR TWENTY
THIRTEEN EVEN MORE SO BY TWENTY
FORTY THE PATHWAY START TO
DIVERGE BASED ON THE RATE OF
ELECTRIFICATION OF ENERGY
DEMANDS AS WELL AS THE ABILITY
TO PLAY EVERITT. RENEWABLES THE
EIGHT EIGHT PLUS OR EIGHT PLUS A
SCENARIO FOR EXAMPLE ASSUMES A
100% RENEWABLES BY TWENTY FIFTY
WHERE AS THE EPLUS ARI MINUS
SCENARIO ASSUMES THAT THE
ABILITY. TO DEPLOY RENEWABLES IS
CONSTRAINED AND NATURAL GAS WITH
CARBON CAPTURE- TAKES A MUCH
LARGER ROLE IN MEETING
ELECTRICITY DEMAND. COULD YOU
GIVE A QUICK EXPLANATION OF THE
E. PLUS THE ARIA YOUR YOUR- YOUR
YOUR- ABBREVIATIONS HERE. SURE
THE RAFT IS OUR REFERENCE
SCENARIO RIGHT SO IT'S NOT
MEETING AFTER- TARGETS- STATIC
POLICY CASE ESSENTIALLY AND THEN
THERE'S THE FOR SET NET ZERO
SCENARIOS EACH CLASS IS- WHAT
THE- COST EFFECTIVE POLICY. ALL
ARE COST EFFECTIVE POLICIES BUT
IT'S ENOUGH CONSIDERING THE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE POLICY I'M- A AND
THERE'S A HIGH RATE OF
ELECTRIFICATION E. MINUS- BEARS. A LOWER RATE OF
ELECTRIFICATION- ECLASS ARE YOU
PLUS IS THE MOUNTIE PLUS EXCEPT
FOR- REQUIRING THAT BY TWENTY
FIFTY WERE MEETING A 100%
RENEWABLE OVER 100% RENEWABLE
TARGET. AND EPLUS ARI MINUS IS
MEANT TO BE THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE MOUNTAIN CASE ON. RENEWABLES
AND INCREASED. THE NATURAL GAS
AND NATURAL GAS WITH BROTHER
NATURAL GAS A CARBON CAPTURE
RIGHT SO- THESE ALL DIFFER IN
TERMS OF THE RATE OF
ELECTRIFICATION AND THE
MAGNITUDE OF RENEWABLE
DEPLOYMENT- SO. I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF
OVERALL ANNUALIZED ENERGY SYSTEM
COSTS AS A PERCENTAGE OF GDP ARE
LOWER FOR ALL NATURAL PATHWAYS
ACROSS FOR A U. S. Y. A RELATIVE
TO A REFERENCE CASE SCENARIO
OVER THE LONG TERM THIS IS OF
COURSE CONTINGENT ON ROBUST LONG
TERM PLANNING POLICY AND THE
ABILITY TO MORE LOCALIZED
INVESTMENT CAPITAL TO DEPLOY
CRITICAL AND INTEGRATED
INFRASTRUCTURE SYSTEMS. SO THESE
TRANSFORMATIONS ARE SUBSTANTIAL
FROM AN INFRASTRUCTURE
PERSPECTIVE IT'S ON A NATIONAL
LEVEL THE DEPLOYMENT RATES OF
SOLAR WIND AND GREAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. ARE MUCH HIGHER
IN ALL OF THEIR NET ZERO
SCENARIOS THAN HISTORICAL PEAK
DEPLOYMENT RATES SO FOR THE U.
S. HISTORICAL. GREAT WAS ABOUT
TEN GIGAWATTS PER YEAR. ROSS THE
DIFFERENT AT ZERO SCENARIOS THAT
WE MODEL. FIFTEEN TO EIGHTY
GIGAWATTS PER YEAR ON AVERAGE
ACROSS THE US WILL HAVE TO BE
DEPLOYED AND THAT RATE IS
UPWARDS OF EIGHT TIMES A START
WILL PEAK RATE SO OUR RATES ARE
REQUIRED. UP FOR WINDOW CROSS
THE LAST. SO TO PUT IT INTO
OTHER CONTEXTS IN THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS OF THE TRANSITION THE
DEPLOYMENT RATE OF SOLAR AND
WIND WILL HAVE TO BE A PUBLIC TO
THE STARKEL MAXIMUM DEPLOYMENT
RATE THAT WE'VE OBSERVED IN THE
US AND IN THE FIVE YEARS AFTER
THAT TO TWENTY THIRTY THIS
DEPLOYMENT RATE WILL HAVE TO
DOUBLE THE DEPLOYMENT RATE
CONTINUES TO ACCELERATE THEIR
AFTER. THERE'S IN A SIMILAR.
PATTERN FOR TRANSMISSION
CAPACITY ACROSS THE US WHICH
NEARLY TRIPLES BY TWENTY FIFTY
AND TO CONTEXTUALIZE THIS AND
TALK ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS
TO BUILD THE CURRENT GRADE. AND
NOW WE'RE WE HAVE TO BUILD THAT
MUCH TRANSMISSION IN THE NEXT
FIFTY YEAR FIFTEEN YEARS AND
THEN AGAIN. IN THE FIFTEEN YEARS
AFTER THAT. COME TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL CONTEXT OF THE SCALE
OF THESE TRANSITIONS THIS MAP IS
A SMOKE TWENTY TWENTY SNAPSHOT
OF UTILITY SCALE SOLAR WHICH IS
SHOWN IN. AN ORANGE WIND IN BLUE
AND TRANSMISSION IN IN GRAY. AND
THIS IS A SNAPSHOT IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN FOR THE ECLASS NETZERO
PATHWAY THAT WE MODELED SO THIS
IS ONE POTENTIAL DEPLOYMENT- OF
BUSINESS ZERO PATHWAY. THAT IS
RELATIVELY MODERATE IN TERMS OF
RENEWABLE DEPLOYMENT SO SOLAR
AND WIND COMPRISE ABOUT 80% OF
ELECTRICITY SUPPLY ACROSS THE U.
S. BY TWENTY FIFTY WHICH EQUATES
TO A TEN FOLD INCREASE IN SOLAR
AND WIND CAPACITY OVER THE NEXT.
THIRTY YEARS. OF COURSE THERE'S
MANY ALTERNATIVE DIPLOMA
PATHWAYS OF SOLAR WIND AND
TRANSMISSION INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA AND REGIONALLY AND
THAT WILL IMPACT OR BE
INFLUENCED BY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
LAND USE ECONOMIC AND POLITICAL
OBJECTIVES. BEYOND RENEWABLE
INFRASTRUCTURE WE ALSO EVALUATED
TRANSITION OF SEVERAL OTHER
TYPES OF INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING THE DEPLOYMENT OF C.
CO TWO PIPELINES AND FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS AND RIPARIAN. SO
THERE WILL ALSO BE SUBSTANTIAL
IMPACTS TO LOCAL AND REGIONAL
ECONOMIES AND SO THIS FIGURE
SHOWS. THAT POTENTIAL FUTURE OF
JOB GAINS AND JOB LOSSES
AGGREGATED BY RESOURCE SECTOR SO
IT INCLUDES ALL SUPPLY SIDE
ENERGY RELATED JOBS IN IN
CALIFORNIA. SO THERE'S A NET JOB
GAIN- IN IN GRADE RELATED JOBS
WHICH IS STRONGER BROWN SOLAR
JOBS AND IN YELLOW. AND GREEN
JOBS IN BLUE. AND THERE'S A NET
LOSS IN OIL AT IN RED AND
NATURAL GAS JOBS IN PURPLE STONE
AGGREGATE INTERVIEW PLUS
SCENARIO. THEIR JOB GAINS OFFSET
JOB LOSSES BUT IN REALITY THOSE-
WHO LOSE JOBS MAY NOT TRANSITION
INTO JOBS IN OF THE LOW CARBON
WORKFORCE. THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE IN OTHER POTENTIAL FUTURES
AND SO YOU CAN SEE A RAPID
GROWTH IN THE ENERGY SECTOR EVEN
EVEN AT BURKE COUNTING FOR ANY
INCREASES IN LABOR PRODUCTIVITY
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASING
AUTOMATION LEARNING- AND LABOR
ECONOMIES OF SCALE. HE'S LABOR
TRANSITIONS MUCH LIKE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TRANSITIONS MUST
BE PLANNED DID MANAGE TO
MITIGATE RISKS AND ACTUALIZE
BENEFITS FOR WORKERS AND
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS REDUCE
TRANSITION RISKS ASSOCIATED WITH
DECARBONISATION. THERE'S
FEEDBACK BETWEEN OUR LABOR
MARKETS TECHNOLOGY COSTS AND
ULTIMATELY HOW WE CHOOSE TO
DEPLOY TECHNOLOGIES AND THE
BILITY TO TRANSITION- IS ALSO
GOING TO BE INFLUENCED BY A
LOCATION ON OCCUPATIONAL COME
FROM TERRY'S FROM EMERGING AND
DECLINING IN INDUSTRIES. IN
ADDITION TO HOW TRANSITIONS ARE
MANAGED AND PLANNED INCLUDING
SUSTAINED WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THE WORKERS AS WELL AS AND
MITIGATE LABOR SUPPLY
BOTTLENECKS. IN A RECENT RELATED
STUDY WE ALSO SHOW THAT
IMPLEMENTING HIGHROAD LABOR
PRACTICES AND POLICIES SUCH AS
PAYING FAIR WAGES AND INCREASING
DOMESTIC CONTENT SHARES OF
RENEWABLE PRODUCTS SUCH AS SOLAR
PANELS AND WIND TURBINES WILL
NOT SLOW THE PACE OF. THE
TRANSITION NOR WILL IT
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASED COSTS.
THERE WILL BE MANY IMPACTS FROM
TRANSITIONING ECONOMY TO MEET
NET ZERO EMISSIONS BY MID
CENTURY AMONG THOSE BE EVALUATED
AIR POLLUTION BENEFITS FROM
REDUCED EMISSIONS OF PRIMARY
FINE PARTICULATE MATTER AND
PRECURSOR POLLUTANTS. CURRENT
ERROR- POLLUTION IMPACTS FROM
FINE PARTICULAR MATTER IN
CALIFORNIA ARE REGRESSIVE SO
IT'S AT THE LOWEST INCOME PEOPLE
HAVE THE HIGHEST MORTALITY RATES
FROM AIR POLLUTION AND IN THE
NEXT DECADE ALONE BY MOVING
TOWARDS A NET ZERO TARGET.
BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED TWO
THOUSAND MORTALITIES WILL BE
AVOIDED AND CALIFORNIA LARGELY
STEMMING FROM TO KERR MISSING
THE TRANSPORTATION TO AND
RESIDENTIAL SECTORS IN THE STATE
THIS IS A QUICKLY TWO FOUR TO
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
AVOIDED AIR POLLUTION DAMAGES.
OVER THE NEXT THIRTY YEARS THE
CUMULATIVE AVOIDED MORTALITIES
ARE ON THE ORDER OF THIRTY
THOUSAND. TO SEVENTY THOUSAND-
APPOINTED MORTALITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE. AND HOW WE
TRANSITION OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
THOUGH WILL INFLUENCE WHO-
BENEFITS AND THE CUMULATIVE
EFFECT ON DIFFERENT POPULATIONS
. SO IN CLOSING THEIR MANY
ALTERNATIVE PATHWAYS TO MEET
THAT ZERO EMISSIONS BY TWENTY-
FIFTY AND IMPORTANTLY WHO DERIVE
THE BENEFITS AND WHO BEARS THE
COST FROM CLIMATE MITIGATION
WILL BE INFLUENCED BY HOW WE
TRANSITION OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WITHOUT AND I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
PROFESSOR MAYFIELD- IT AYE I
RECEIVED A REQUEST TO THAT- IT
BECAUSE SO YOU- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MAY HAVE TO. IT TOO TO
LEAVE EARLY WHAT WOULD YOU BE
ABLE TO. TO STAY IT GIG CAN WE
HAVE ALL OF OUR PRESENTERS
PRESENT AND THEN. COME BACK TO
YOU FOR QUESTIONS. THAT'S FINE
YES OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT- SO- WITH THAT- I'D
LIKE TO INVITE TO. OUR NEXT
PRESENTER- FOUR PANEL TO TRADE
OFFS OF ACCELERATED ACTION IN
SPECIFIC SECTORS- PERHAPS WELL I
THINK I WAS GONNA INVITE ALL
THREE TWO TO COME AT THE TABLE
BUT I GUESS THAT MAY VIOLATE
OUR- OUR ONGOING COVERT
PRECAUTIONS AND SO- LIKE TO
INVITE TO THE- DOCTOR CHRIS
BUSH. A RESEARCH DIRECTOR WITH
ENERGY INNOVATION.
REMOVE THIS THAT'S OKAY WITH
EVERYONE WE AN HEAR YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD- OKAY. A REBEL CHAIR
VICE CHAIR DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE PRIVILEGE OF
ADDRESSING YOU TODAY I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE MY
PRESENTATION IN HARD COPY IN
FRONT OF YOU- SAUGUS STARTED IF
THAT'S OKAY- CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE. POLICY LEADER FOR THE
UNITED STATES IN THE WORLD. BUT
WE'RE NOT ON TRACK TO MEET OUR
TWENTY THIRTY OR TWENTY FORTY
FIVE GOALS. THIS IS ALL THE MORE
WORRISOME BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
ALSO MUST STRENGTHEN OUR FUTURE
TARGETS TO ALIGN WITH THE LATEST
SCIENCE. CALIFORNIA IS ALSO ON
TRACK TO DELIVER CLEAN AIR FOR
ALL OUR RESIDENTS BY TWENTY
THIRTY. AND THOSE SUFFERING FROM
AIR POLLUTION TYPICALLY
CONTRIBUTE THE LEAST AND CAN
LEAST AFFORD TO ESCAPE IT. OF
COURSE THERE'S GOOD NEWS AS WELL
OUR ELECTRIC POWER SECTOR IS
JUST DECARBONIZING AT INCREDIBLE
SPEED IN CALIFORNIA POLICY
PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE. IN JUMP
STARTING THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
MARKET. NOW THE STATE MUST DO
THE SAME TO SPEED THE ADOPTION
OF HEAT PUMPS IN BUILDINGS AND
INDUSTRY. PHASING OUT FOSSIL
FUELS AND REPLACING THEM WITH
CLEAN AFFORDABLE ENERGY ENERGY
SOURCES CAN HELP CALIFORNIA
BUILD A STRONGER FAIRER ECONOMY.
AMBITIOUS POLICIES WILL SPUR A
NEW WAVE OF INNOVATION AND
ENTREPRENEURIAL ISM AND CLEAN
TECHNOLOGIES INCREASING IN
DEMAND WORLDWIDE.
ELECTRIFICATION POLICIES REDUCE
CALIFORNIA'S EXPOSURE TO
VOLATILE FOSSIL FUEL PRICES A
NOTABLE ADVANTAGE WHEN GAS
PRICES ARE SPIKING DUE TO
RUSSIA'S WAR AGAINST UKRAINE. MY
TESTIMONY SPOTS LIKE THE
SPOTLIGHTS THE POTENTIAL TO
ELECTRIFY ENERGY USE IN FOOD
PROCESSING ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
LARGEST INDUSTRIES AND URGES
FASTER TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION AS WELL.
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP HAS
PROVIDED CRUCIAL MOMENTUM FOR
INTERNATIONAL CLIMATE EFFORTS
BUT WE MUST NOT RELENT. HUMANITY
STILL HAS A CHANCE TO LIMIT
GLOBAL WARMING TO ONE POINT FIVE
DEGREES CELSIUS THIS I JUST URGE
BUT SUCCESS HINGES ON
CALIFORNIA'S RECOMMITMENT TO BE
AT THE FOREFRONT. OF AMBITION.
SO WITH THAT LET'S MOVE ON TO
THE SECOND SLIDE SLIDE WHICH-
LOOKS AT THE STATE'S EMISSION
INVENTORY BACK TO ITS ORIGIN IN
THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND. AND ON
THE RIGHT HAND SIDE SHOWS
FIGURES GRAPHING FIVE TEN AND
TWENTY YEAR MISSION REDUCTION
POINT TRENDS SHOWING LITTLE
ACCELERATION IN THOSE TRENDS
OVER TIME. MOVING TO THE NEXT
SLIDE. TITLED LOOKING FORWARD
NOT ON TRACK. THIS GRAPH
PROJECTS THE FIVE YEAR EMISSION
REDUCTION TREND FORWARD SHOWING
THAT REACHING OUR EXISTING
TWENTY THIRTY TARGET WILL
REQUIRE MORE THAN TRIPLING THE
ANNUAL ANNUAL REDUCTION RATE
COMPARED TO THE FIVE YEAR TREND
IN THE MOST RECENT DATA. THE
FACT THAT WE ARE NOT ON TRACK
FOR THE TWENTY THREE TARGET
UNDERLINES THE LIMITATIONS AND
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWO SCOPING
FINAL SCOPING PLAN LANGUAGE.
ONLY NEW STATUTORY LANGUAGE CAN
INSURE ECONOMY WHY TARGETS ARE
TRANSLATED INTO POLICY ACTION.
NEXT SLIDE PLEASE THE ONE TITLED
CALIFORNIA ENERGY POLICY
SIMULATOR. AND THE N. THE
OBVIOUS NEED FOR STRONGER ACTION
DOES NOT TRANSLATE TO SIMPLE
CHOICES FOR POLICY MAKERS I
DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU THAT.
ENERGY INNOVATION DEVELOPED ARE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY POLICY
SIMULATOR TO HELP IDENTIFY THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND SOCIALLY
ADVANTAGEOUS POLICY
COMBINATIONS. ARE OPEN SOURCE
MODEL IS AVAILABLE AT CALIFORNIA
DOT ENERGY POLICY DOT SOLUTIONS
AND IS FREELY DOWNLOADABLE THE
CALIFORNIA EPS MODELS AFFECTS OF
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM AND
SECTOR SPECIFIC POLICIES SUCH AS
THE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD AND
WHEN RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO
STANDARD. WE ARE UPDATING OUR
MODEL AND A DISSIPATED THIS IN
THE NEXT QUARTER QUARTER. ENERGY
INNOVATION RELEASED THE FIRST
VERSION OF OUR MODEL IN EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY EVALUATING THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SCOPING PLAN
STRATEGY WE CONCLUDED EXISTING
POLICIES WERE UNLIKELY TO
DELIVER TWENTY THIRTY SUCCESS.
WE OFFERED RECOMMENDATIONS EVERY
MAJOR SECTOR TO CLOSE THIS
POLICY GAP. AND NOW MOVE ON TO
THE- SLIDE ENTITLED
ELECTRIFICATION OPPORTUNITY IN
FOOD PROCESSING. AND SEVERAL OF
OUR RECKLESS RECOMMENDATIONS-
FROM THE CALIFORNIA EPS MODELING
ARE NOW REFLECTED IN CURRENT
POLICY ONE THAT'S NOT YET
ADOPTED UP VERGES AS ZERO
EMISSION STANDARD TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF EXISTING
TECHNOLOGIES FOR ELECTRIFYING
INDUSTRY HEAT. THIS LIGHTS SPOT
LIGHTS IN ELECTRIFICATION
OPPORTUNITY. BECAUSE FOOD
PROCESSING CONSUMES MORE NATURAL
GAS THAN ANY CALIFORNIA INDUSTRY
EXCEPT FOR OIL INCLUDING
EXTRACTION AND REFINING. THESE
DATA ILLUSTRATE THAT FOOD
PROCESSING STANDS OUT FOR ITS
DEMAND FOR LOW TEMPERATURE HEAT
WHICH IS READILY SERVED BY HEAT
PUMPS EXISTING TECHNOLOGY. HEAT
PUMPS BUT HE BLOW 100 DEGREES
CELSIUS REPRESENTS OVER 40% OF
HEAT REQUIRED FOR FEW PROP FOOD
PROCESSING MORE THAN ANY OTHER
INDUSTRY. STRONGER POLICY IN
INDUSTRY IS NEEDED BECAUSE OF
SURPLUS ALLOW SUPPLY IN CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM A KEY INDUSTRY
POLICY. THE INDEPENDENT MISSION
MARKET ADVISORY COMMITTEE
RECENTLY FOUND THE PRIVATE BANK
OF ALLOWANCES HAS GROWN TO
EXCEED THREE HUNDRED MILLION
TONS. IN ADDITION TO OVERSUPPLY
CONCERNS CONTINUING FREE
ALLOCATION TO CALIFORNIA
INDUSTRY UNDERCUTS THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF CARBON PRICING
. NOT MOVING TO THE NEXT SLIDE
WHICH LISTS SEVERAL- EQUIPMENT
AND DEVICE LIFETIMES. CALIFORNIA
SHOULD STRIVE FOR ALL NEW CAR
SALES TO BE ZERO EMISSION AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
EVERY NEW GAS POWERED CAR THE
ROAD. CREATES FUTURE LIABILITIES
THIS CALIFORNIA DRIVES TOWARDS
CARBON NEUTRALITY THE TIME OF
INVESTMENT WHEN BUSINESSES ARE
CHOIR NEW CAPITAL EQUIPMENT OR
WHEN CONSUMERS ARE BUYING CARS
AND FURNACES. IS A CRUCIAL TIME
FOR POLICY BECAUSE OF THESE
MACHINES LASTING TEN YEARS OR
MORE. THIS MOMENT OF REPLACEMENT
CREATES A POLICY WINDOW OF
OPPORTUNITY FOR EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. ONCE PEOPLE INVEST
IN FOSSIL FUEL MACHINES THEY
TAKE ON A LIFE OF THEIR OWN
FORCING MACHINES INTO EARLY
RETIREMENT IS MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT AND COSTLY THAN
SHARING CLEAN INVESTMENTS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. NEXT I'D LIKE TO
LOOK AT A SLIDE UP ENTITLED
LEARNING CURVES IN INNOVATION
OPPORTUNITIES. AND IT IT IT IT
POINTS TO THE GROWING UP SIDES
OF THE EASY TRANSITION- AND
THAT'S ANOTHER REASON CALIFORNIA
HAS TO EXCEL RATE THE TIMETABLE
AND EV'S ALREADY SAVING
CONSUMERS ON FUEL AND
MAINTENANCE AND WILL SOON COST
LESS DUE TO LEARNING CURVE
EFFECTS WHICH QUANTIFY HOW
GREATER EXPERIENCE WITH EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES. RESULTS IN
LEARNING BY DOING AND ECONOMIES
OF SCALE THIS GRAPH SHOWS HOW
EASY BATTERY PACK COSTS OF FALL
89% IN REAL TERMS OVER THE LAST
DECADE AND PROMISING ALTERNATIVE
BATTERY CHEMISTRIES AN
ADDITIONAL KIND OF MUSE A SCALAR
REASONS TO EXPECT CONTINUING
INNOVATION AND FALLING COSTS FOR
BATTERIES. I'D LIKE TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE RED CURVES IN
THIS GRAPH IN PARTICULAR WHICH
SHOW PAST FORECASTS OF
INFLUENTIAL ENERGY ECONOMY
MODELERS SUCH AS THE-
INTERNATIONAL ENERGY AGENCY.
THESE PAST FORECASTS FAILED TO
ANTICIPATE CONTINUED INNOVATION
AND ILLUSTRATE THAT CLEAN TECH
FOR COST FORECASTS ARE ALMOST
ALWAYS TOO CONSERVATIVE. A
NOTABLE EXCEPTON IS WORK BY
PROFESSOR KAMAN AND COLLEAGUES.
USING TWENTY FIFTEEN DATA HE AND
CO AUTHORS HARNESS THE POWER OF
LEARNING CURVES T FORECAST
TWENTY TWENTY E. V. BATTERY PACK
PRICES WITH 98% ACCURACY. NOW
CLOSING WITH THE SLIDE CALLED
THE EEVEE INTO THE V. INDUSTRY
AS A CASE STUDY IN ECONOMIC
UPSIDES IT. SHOWS THE ALL TOO
OFTEN IGNORED ECONOMIC UPSIDES
OF THE STATE'S CLIMATE POLICY
LEADERSHIP. TODAY CALIFORNIA
BOASTS MORE THAN NINETEEN
THOUSAND AUTO MANUFACTURING JOBS
DOUBLE THEIR HISTORICAL LEVELS.
AND OVERALL THE EEVEE INDUSTRIES
CREATED OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DIRECT
JOBS PAYING AN ANNUAL WAGE OF
NINETY ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS ACCORDING TO THE
L. A. COUNTY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION. AND
WITH THAT I'LL CONCLUDE MY TEST
TESTIMONY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM MY FELLOW PANELISTS
AND- TO THE DISCUSSIONS TO COME
. AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
LIKE WITH THE- FIRST MAYFIELD WE
APPRECIATE IF- I BEGAN HAVING UP
TO ASK QUESTIONS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT NEXT- LIKE TO INVITE THE-
DR REBEKAH DEL. PROGRAM DIRECTOR
FOR CLIMATE WORKS FOUNDATION.
IS THIS ALL. YEAH OKAY GREAT. SO
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
THE MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON CLIMATE
CHANGE POLICIES FOR ALL THE HARD
WORK THAT THEY DO ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME AND DISCUSS THIS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ISSUE TODAY. THE ISSUE
BEFORE US OF WHETHER TO
ACCELERATE CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
TARGETS AND CLIMATE ACTIONS
COULD NOT BE MORE IMPORTANT- I'D
LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THE CRITICAL
ROLE OF CALIFORNIA'S INDUSTRIAL
SECTOR. IN THIS POLICY PROCESS.
AND FOCUS ON THE FOLLOWING THREE
POINTS. FIRST CALIFORNIA CANNOT
MEET. ITS CLIMATE GOALS WITHOUT
DRAMATICALLY DECREASING ITS
INDUSTRIAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. SECOND CALIFORNIA'S
MANUFACTURING SECTOR IS
ESSENTIAL TO THE SUCCESS OF ITS
ECONOMY AND THE WELL BEING OF
ITS CITIZENS SO ALL OF OUR
ACTIONS ON INDUSTRIAL EMISSIONS
SHOULD BE DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
AND INCREASE THE SUCCESS OF
MANUFACTURING IN OUR STATE. AND
THIRD THE CEMENT INDUSTRY
PRESENTS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS MULTIPLE GOALS. REDUCING
OUR STATE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS INCREASING OUR GLOBAL
GREENHOUSE GAS LEADERSHIP
MAINTAINING OUR MANUFACTURING
BASE AND IMPROVING PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALL AT
THE SAME TIME. SO LET ME TAKE
THOSE THREE POINTS ONE. AT A
TIME AND DIVE A LITTLE DEEPER ON
EACH STARTING WITH THE
IMPORTANCE OF CALIFORNIA'S
INDUSTRIAL EMISSIONS. ALMOST A
QUARTER OF CALIFORNIA'S
GREENHOUSE GASES COME FROM
INDUSTRY. THIS IS SIMPLY TOO
MUCH TO LEAVE TO THE SINGLE
POLICY MECHANISM OF THE CAP AND
TRADE SYSTEM. THESE EMISSIONS
ARE ROUGHLY SPLIT BETWEEN THE
UPSTREAM MIDDLES ARE MIDSTREAM
AND DOWNSTREAM EMISSIONS OF THE
OIL AND GAS INDUSTRY. AND
MANUFACTURING ACTIVITIES. MOST
OF THE TRAJECTORY OF THE OIL AND
GAS SECTORS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS WILL BE DETERMINED BY
WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. AND NOT
AT THE INDUSTRIAL SITES
THEMSELVES SO I'M GONNA FOCUS
THE REST OF MY REMARKS ON THE
EMISSIONS FROM MANUFACTURING
ACTIVITIES. SO WHICH BRINGS ME
TO MY SECOND POINT CALIFORNIA'S
MANUFACTURING SECTOR IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALL BE
JUSTLY PROUD OFF. HI IT PRODUCES
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
IN ECONOMIC OUTPUT THIS IS THE
LARGEST MANUFACTURING SECTOR OF
ANY STATE IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND THAT'S NOT JUST BECAUSE OUR
ECONOMY IS THE LARGEST WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A LARGER
PERCENTAGE OF OUR STATE ECONOMIC
OUTPUT COMING FROM
MANUFACTURING. THEN THE U. S.
ECONOMY AS A WHOLE- FUSING. AT
LEAST AS IMPORTANT AS THE
OVERALL IMPACT ON OUR OUR
ECONOMIC OUTPUT IS THE QUALITY
OF THE JOBS THAT THE
MANUFACTURING SECTOR GENERATES
THE TOTAL COMPENSATION OF THE
AVERAGE MANUFACTURING WORKER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS A
HUNDRED TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR. THIS IS WAY ABOVE
AVERAGE AND AS SUCH. AW THE
CALIFORNIA THE MANUFACTURING%
SECTOR PROVIDES CRITICAL LADDER
INTO THE MIDDLE CLASS FOR A WIDE
VARIETY OF CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF A COLLEGE
EDUCATION. HOWEVER IN SPITE OF
ALL OF THIS BY FAR THE SIMPLEST
AND MOST DIRECT ROUTE TO
DECARBONIZE OUR MANUFACTURING
SECTOR IS ALSO THE WORST IT'S
SIMPLY TO SHUT DOWN THE
FACILITIES. THAT WOULD ELIMINATE
THE EMISSIONS DIRECTLY BUT IT
WOULD CAUSE ALL MANNER OF OUR
ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL PROBLEMS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WELL FAILING
TO ACTUALLY REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS ON A GLOBAL BASIS
. SO TO AVOID THE US WE NEED A
COMBINATION OF POLICIES. THAT
REQUIRE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AT FACILITIES WITH
AND USE THOSE IN COMBINATION
WITH POLICIES THAT CREATE
BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
CLEANEST FIRMS. WHEN POLICIES
THAT SUPPORT INNOVATION IN
TECHNOLOGY MARKETS AND BUSINESS
MODELS. SO FINALLY TO ILLUSTRATE
HOW ALL OF THIS MIGHT WORK I
WANT TO FOCUS FOR THE LAST FEW
MINUTES OF MY- TESTIMONY ON THE
CEMENT SECTOR. THE CEMENT SECTOR
IS THE LARGEST SOURCE OF
MANUFACTURING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH BETWEEN TWO AND
3% OF TOTAL STATE EMISSIONS. AT
THAT LEVEL IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT
WE REDUCE THESE EMISSIONS. JUST
IN ORDER TO MEET OUR OVERALL
CHEMICALS THAT'S THAT'S TOO MANY
TONS OF GREENHOUSE GASES FOR US
TO IGNORE. HOWEVER GLOBALLY THE
CEMENT SECTOR IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
BETWEEN SEVEN AND 8% OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. SO IF
CALIFORNIA CONTENT DEMONSTRATE
TECHNICAL POLICY AND BUSINESS
FEASIBILITY OF GENUINELY LOW OR
NEAR ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS CEMENT
PRODUCTION. THAT'S A HUGE
OPPORTUNITY FOR GLOBAL
LEADERSHIP THIS IS A REALLY HIGH
LEVERAGE OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA SO WE NEED TO DO IT
FOR IT FOR OURSELVES. BUT IT'S A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
CONTRIBUTE TO SOLVING THE
PROBLEM GLOBALLY- AS OF RIGHT
NOW NO ONE HAS FIGURED OUT HOW
TO HAVE A GENUINELY ZERO OR NEAR
ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS CEMENT
INDUSTRY. SO CALIFORNIA CAN BE A
TRAILBLAZER HERE. IN ADDITION TO
THESE CONSIDERATIONS ALL I TWO
MORE FIRST. AS WE JUST HEARD
FROM ALL OF THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS IN ORDER TO MEET OUR
OVERALL ECONOMY WIDE CLIMATE
GOALS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
BUILD A LOT OF STUFF WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO BUILD NEW HOUSING NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE NEW TRANSMISSION
LINES ALL OF THAT IS GOING TO
REQUIRE CEMENT AND CONCRETE WE
DO NOT WANT OUR ACTIONS. TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE TO
THEMSELVES BECOME DRIVERS OF
ADDITIONAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS THROUGH THE DIRTY
BUILDING MATERIALS THAT ALL OF
THIS CLEAN STUFF IS MADE OUT OF
. SECOND CEMENT FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOTABLY DIRTY IN
THE SENSE THAT THEY ARE THEY
HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE A
MISSIONS OF THE LOCAL POLLUTANTS
ARE BOTH CRITERIA AIR POLLUTANTS
AND AIR TOXICS THAT HAVE A VERY
MALIGN EFFECT ON THE COMMUNITIES
THAT LIVE AROUND THEM CEMENT
KILNS ARE THE ONLY FACILITIES
LEFT IN CALIFORNIA THAT STILL
RELY PRIMARILY ON BURNING COAL
FOR THEIR ENERGY AND POTS- AND
BECAUSE THESE ARE RELATIVELY
SMALL FACILITIES AND BECAUSE SO
MUCH OF THE ATTENTION HAS BEEN
FOCUSED ON POWER GENERATION. AW
THEY'VE CUT THEY'VE MANAGED TO
SLIP BY UNDER THE RADAR FOR MANY
YEARS. SO FOR ALL THESE REASONS
CEMENT IS CRITICAL. AND TO DO IT
WE NEED A COMPREHENSIVE POLICY
APPROACH WE CAN BUILD ON THE
FOUNDATION FROM CAP OF CAP AND
TRADE APPS BY INCREASING AND
BETTER TARGETING THE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE TO CAP AND TRADE
CREATES TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND ADDRESS THE
OVERHANG OF BANK EMISSIONS THAT
BOB MY COLLEAGUES ON THE PANEL
ALREADY MENTIONED. SECOND. WE
NEED TO SUPPORT INNOVATION ARE
UNLIKE MANY INDUSTRIES LESS THAN
HALF OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM THE CEMENT
INDUSTRY COMES FROM ENERGY
EMISSIONS WITH MOST COMING FROM
THE RAW MATERIALS IT'S LITERALLY
CO TWO COMING STRAIGHT OUT OF
THE ROCKS. AND AS SUCH ALL THE
CLEAN ENERGY IN THE WORLD WILL
AT BEST GET US MAYBE 40%
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS FROM THIS
CRITICAL SECTOR. SO INNOVATION
IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT HERE.
AND WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
DISCUSSION TODAY ABOUT CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE. AND MY
ATTITUDE IS. IF WE HAVE OP IF WE
DECIDE EVEN IF WE DECIDE THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO USE CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE IN ANY OTHER PART OF
OUR ECONOMY. THE PLACE WHERE IT
IS MOST LIKELY TO BE ESSENTIAL
TO MEETING OUR CLIMATE GOALS IS
IN THE CEMENT INDUSTRY- SO IF WE
WANT TO TAKE ACTION ON. FIFTY S.
CEMENT IS THE PLACE TO START- SO
WE NEED TO SUPPORT TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATION DIRECTLY- AND TO
FACILITATE EARLY DEPLOYMENTS
WITH THINGS LIKE SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE BOTH FINANCIALLY
AND ALSO SUPPORTING AND
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE
PLANNING AND PERMITTING
REGULATORY SUPPORT FOR
GEOLOGICAL STORAGE- AND TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE ABUNDANCE
FEDERAL MONEY FROM THE RECENT
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT AND
JOBS ACT. THAT IS AVAILABLE TO
STATES WHO WISH TO BE AGGRESSIVE
ON THIS TOPIC AND I WANT TO
POINT OUT THE CALIFORNIA CEMENT
COMPANIES. ALONG WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR UNIONS. AND CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS ALL REALIZE
THE NEED FOR THIS ACTION. THE
CEMENT COMPANIES UNDERSTAND
WHICH DIRECTION HISTORY IS
MOVING IN AND THEY WOULD LIKE TO
DECARBONISE THE FACILITIES
PROVIDED THAT WE CAN CREATE A
POLICY SITUATION. THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO DO THAT WITHOUT LOSING
MONEY. FINALLY WE NEED POLICIES
THAT CREATE MARKETS FOR CLEAN
CEMENT. CALIFORNIA IS A GLOBAL
LEADER IN ITS BY CLEAN POLICY TO
BUY CLEAN BUILDING MATERIALS FOR
STATE FUNDED TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS WITHOUT POLICY ACTUALLY
EXEMPTS THE MOST IMPORTANT
BUILDING MATERIAL NAMELY CEMENT
OR CONCRETE- WE SHOULD ALSO BE
EXPLORING POLICIES. LIKE THE
CLEAN PRODUCT STANDARDS
ADDRESSING EMBODIED CARBON
THROUGH OTHER AN INTERESTING
ADDRESSING EMBODIED CARBON IN
THE BUILT ENVIRONMENT THROUGH
OTHER MECHANISMS LIKE THROUGH
OUR BUILDING CODES. SO IN THE UC
CONCLUSION WE NEED TO DDRESS
INDUSTRIAL GREENHOUSE GASES IT'S
NOT OPTIONAL WE NEED TO DO IT IN
A WAY THAT SUPPORTS AND
STRENGTHENS OUR MANUFACTURING
SECTOR. AND A COMPREHENSIVE
POLICY APPROACH INCLUDING
REGULATION INNOVATION AND MARKET
CREATION IS A WAY TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH LAST
BUT NOT LEAST TOOK- WE WOULD
LIKE TO- INVITES TO DOCTOR DAN
KAMIN PROFESSOR OF ENERGY- UC
BERKELEY.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THE CHANCE
TO SPEAK TODAY I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING BECAUSE AS YOU'VE HEARD
FROM A COMBINATION OF MODELING
PERSPECTIVES TODAY AND FROM
SPECIFIC SECTORAL APPROACHES WE
NEED TO ACCELERATE THE
ACTIVITIES IN CALIFORNIA NOT
ONLY FOR OUR OWN BENEFIT BEFORE
THE GOAL BENEFIT. AND THAT
REALLY STARTS WITH THE WORK OF
THIS COMMITTEE SO I WILL TRY TO
SKIP OVER ELEMENTS OF MY OF MY
COMMENTS THAT WERE ADDRESSED BY
OTHERS I GUESS I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT TWO THINGS THAT I
HEARD CLEARLY IN THE OF IN THE
PRIOR TO SPEAKERS DR BUSH INTO A
DOCTOR DEL. AND THAT IS WE HAVE
SPECIFIC SECTORAL OPPORTUNITIES
THAT WILL NOT UNFORTUNATELY
EMERGE FROM LARGE SCALE MODELING
EFFORTS I AM MYSELF A PHYSICIST
AND ENERGY MODELER I'VE BEEN
DOING ENERGY MODELING FOR TWENTY
YEARS MALAI SWITCH MODEL IS ONE
OF THE ONES THE STATE IS USED
OVER AND OVER AGAIN IT'S BEEN
SUPPORTED BY THE CCV ARP
OVERTIME. AND MODELS ARE
INHERENTLY CONSERVATIVE AND I
DON'T MEAN WE DON'T LOOK AT
SCENARIOS THAT ARE FAR AND WIDE
WHAT I MEAN IS THAT MODELS TEND
TO BE REACTIVE. WHEN SOMETHING
GOES RIGHT LIKE THE PUSH TO
ELECTRIC VEHICLES OR EFFORTS TO
DEPLOY HEAT PUMPS OR BATTERIES.
MODELS GRAB ONTO IT AND PROJECT
DRAMATIC IMPROVEMENTS OVER TIME.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO WHETHER IT'S
THE INTERNATIONAL ENERGY AGENCY
THE E. THREE MODEL MICE WHICH
MODEL THE REFLEX MODEL ANY OF
THEM. THAT'S NOT A CRITICISM OF
MODELS. WHAT MODELS ARE BEST AT
IS CHARTING LEAST COST LEAST
RISK STRATEGIES NOT ACTUALLY IN
LAYING OUT BOLD ACTIONS TO BEGIN
WITH SO I WANTED TO SPEND A
MINUTE. CONGRATULATING THE STATE
FOR WHAT WE'VE DONE BECAUSE I
THINK IT REALLY SETS THE
OPPORTUNITY IN THE AGENDA AND I
GO BACK TO SOME OF THE BILLS
THAT- OF THAT THAT THAT THAT
THAT AFTER JUST OUTRAGEOUS ANTI
SKINNER PASSED IN OTHERS THAT
HIGHLIGHTED AGGRESSIVE
ACTIVITIES IN RESTAURANTS AND
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT- THAT
CENTER BECKER HAS DONE IN TERMS
OF LOOKING ECONOMY WIDE. WHEN
CALIFORNIA PASSED SB ONE THE
MILLION SOLAR ROOF MANDATE. THE
GLOBAL STATEMENT WAS IT'S NOT
POSSIBLE IN THE TIME TO SEE IN
THE TIME SCANNED CALIFORNIA
SENATE. WE MET THAT GOAL. WHEN
CALIFORNIA SET THE GOAL FOR
MILLION ELECTRIC VEHICLES WE
DIDN'T MAKE IT EXACTLY THE TEN
YEARS. BUT YOU CAN ARGUE THAT
NOT ONLY THAT MANDATE BUT MANY
OF THE OTHER PIECES THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD THAT I
HELPED TO WRITE A NUMBER OF
OTHER FEATURES. BROUGHT NOT ONLY
A MILLION ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO
CALIFORNIA. BUT IT ALSO
ACCELERATE THE GLOBAL PROSPECTS.
I WORKED HARD ON ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE FOURTEEN THE CALL
FOR THE ONE POINT TWO GIGA WATTS
OF ENERGY STORAGE IN CALIFORNIA
BY TWENTY TWENTY. SOMETHING THAT
WAS ALSO SAID TO BE IMPOSSIBLE.
WE NOW IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE HAD
THE MOSS LANDING STORAGE PLANT.
GO ONLINE WITH PLANS TO EQUAL
THE ENTIRE CAPACITY. OF TWENTY
FIVE FOURTEEN ONE POINT TWO
GIGAWATTS BY TWENTY TWENTY BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR OR EARLY
NEXT YEAR. THOSE ARE ALL ACTIONS
THAT I WISH WE AS ENERGY
MODELERS HAD FORECAST. BUT IN
EVERY SINGLE CASE WE DID NOT.
WHAT HAPPENED IN EACH CASE WAS A
BOLD ACTION BY A MIXTURE OF
CALIFORNIA SENATE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEES. CONVERSATIONS WITH
INDUSTRY TO HIGHLIGHT WHAT WAS
POSSIBLE I KNOW THAT'S THE
HISTORY YOU WILL KNOW. BUT IT'S
CRITICAL IN THINKING THROUGH THE
NEXT STEPS TO GET US BACK ON
TRACK AS AS DR BUSH'S AS AS
HIGHLIGHTED WE NEED TO DO THAT
AND THE CRITICAL MESSAGE OF MY
TESTIMONY. IS THAT WHILE
CALIFORNIA IS NOT CURRENTLY ON
PATH TO MEET THOSE TARGETS.
GETTING ON THOSE ARE GETTING
BACK ON THAT PATHWAY WILL BE
GOOD FOR THE CLIMATE GOOD FOR
THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT THE MOST
CRITICALLY GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA
JOBS. AT THE POINTS THAT WE WERE
PUSHING THOSE SOLAR STORAGE AND
OTHER MANDATES. CALIFORNIA WAS
BRINGING IN UP 240% OF TOTAL
NATIONAL FUNDING FOR VENTURE
CAPITAL THE CLEANTECH SPACE.
THAT IS FULL OF THE THAT'S THE
OPPORTUNITY ON THE LEGACY HERE
AND SO AGAIN I'M TO SKIP OVER
MANY OF THE DETAILS BUT TO TRY
TO REMAIN ON TARGET. LET ME JUST
HIGHLIGHT ONE LAST POINT AND
THEN GO TO A SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE FIRST IS
THE CALIFORNIA'S UNFORTUNATELY
DONE ITSELF SOME SIGNIFICANT
RECENT DAMAGE. ONE OF THOSE
AREAS IS THE WELL MEANING BUT
VERY PROBLEMATIC DETAILS. OF THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
PROPOSED RULING ON SOLAR. THAT
HAS DESTROYED CONFIDENCE IN THE
AGGRESSIVE MOVING FORWARD IN
SOLAR. AND WITH SOLAR AND WIND
NOW THE CHEAPEST NEW FORMS OF
ENERGY TECHNOLOGY SOMETHING WE
HEAR ALL THE TIME BUT THE
CONTEXT IS IT IS NOW CHEAPER TO
BUILD NEW SOLAR AND WIND ENERGY
FACILITIES. THEN IT IS TO
OPERATE FOSSIL FUEL PLANTS. AND
EVEN WHEN WE ADD IN STORAGE TO
THAT MIX SO SOLAR PLUS STORAGE
OR WIND PLUS STORAGE THOSE
FACILITIES ARE ALSO NOT ONLY
CHEAPER. BUT THEY GENERATE
TWENTY TO A 100% MORE JOBS IN
THE FOSSIL FUEL OPPORTUNITIES
AND THIS I THINK IS ONE OF THE
REALLY EXCELLENT POINTS THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF FLOOR BROUGHT
UP AND THAT IS. SOME OF OUR
OPPORTUNITIES GOING FORWARD OR
DO INVEST IN THE AREAS THAT ARE
OT URBAN CORES WHERE WE HAVE
THE CAPITAL WHERE WE HAVE THE
DENSITY OF DEMAND. BUT IT'S TO
REALLY BUILD UP OTHER PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA'S BASE. TO BECOME
LEADERS IN THESE OTHER AREAS SO
FAR TO RUN THROUGH QUITE QUICKLY
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT I
LISTED ON THE SECOND PAGE OF MY
TESTIMONY. FIRST AND SEVERAL
PEOPLE HAVE SAID VERSIONS OF IT.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BRING FORWARD
TO THE TWENTY THIRTY FIVE DATE
FOR THE END OF SALES OF NEW
INTERNAL COMBUSTION VEHICLES TO
TWENTY THIRTY OR EARLIER ALREADY
THE UNITED KINGDOM AND
MASSACHUSETTS IN WATCHING OUR
ACTIONS HAVE MOVED TO THAT DATE
. THAT EARLIER DATE IS NOT A JOB
KILLER IT IS NOT AN ANTI RURAL A
STATEMENT IT IS A STATEMENT OF
INVESTING IN INNOVATION BECAUSE
THE AREAS WHERE WE NEED. NEW
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES- TRIED ARE
IN THE AGRICULTURE SECTOR AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- FLOOR
HIGHLIGHTED THEIR FOR HEAVY
INDUSTRY THERE TO WORK AT PORTS
. THOSE ARE ALL OPPORTUNITIES TO
INVEST IN ELECTRIC VEHICLES ANY
NEAR TERM OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HYDROGEN VEHICLES. VERY RECENTLY
UNITED KINGDOM HAS DEVOTED ITS
LARGEST AND TUSKER INDUSTRIAL
CLUSTER. THE HUMBER CLUSTER TO
BECOME AN ENTIRELY GREEN
HYDROGEN FUNDED OPPORTUNITY AND
MAKE IT GETS BACK TO THE BUT THE
POINT MADE BY SOMEBODY MEMBER
GARCIA. ABOUT THE NEED TO INVEST
AND TO DEAL WITH THE SO CALLED
DOCKER. IN FACT THE WORRISOME
DOCKER. HAS BECOME AN
OPPORTUNITY WHAT WE ONCE LOOKED
AT FROM THE MODELING PERSPECTIVE
AS A CHALLENGE OF FINDING VALUE
FOR CLEAN ENERGY BECAUSE OF A
SMALL THE LOW MARGINAL COST FOR
CLEAN ENERGY DURING THE DAY. HAS
BECOME AN OPPORTUNITY TO POWER
VEHICLES AND TO MAKE HYDROGEN
WHEN THE DEMAND FOR ELECTRICITY
IS LOW. THAT LEADS TO ONE OF THE
OF MY OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS AND
THAT IS THIS COMMITTEE WORKING
WITH THE PLANNING COMMITTEE IS
WORKING WITH- WITH WITH THE U.
S. NAVY. NEEDS TO ACCELERATE OUR
DEPLOYMENT PLANS FOR OFFSHORE
WIND. OFFSHORE WIND IS A HUGE
RESOURCES FOR THE WESTERN UNITED
STATES IN PARTICULAR CALIFORNIA.
AND LAST WEEK'S AUCTIONS OF EAST
COAST- BLOCKS FOR OFF SHORE WIND
BROUGHT IN FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
. THOSE ARE ESTIMATED TO PRODUCE
IN THE LONG RUN EIGHTY THOUSAND
NEW JOBS THAT'S ROUGHLY
EQUIVALENT TO THE U. S. TO THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR INDUSTRY TODAY.
AGGRESSIVELY MOVING HALL FORWARD
ON PILOT PROJECTS IN OFFSHORE
WIND WILL GENERATE CLEAN
ELECTRICITY WHEN DEMAND IS HIGH
AND CLEAN HYDROGEN WHEN DEMAND
IS LOW. CALIFORNIA SHOULD ALSO
WORK AGGRESSIVELY WITH THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO TRY TO
OVERTURN- OR TO WORK AROUND THE
HIGHLY UNFORTUNATE DECISION BY
LOUISIANA JUDGE TO BLOCK THE
SOCIAL COST OF CARBON. ONE OF
THE WAYS THAT CALIFORNIA CAN BE
A LEADER IN THIS AREA IS TO
UTILIZE A SOCIAL COST OF CARBON
THAT REFLECTS RACIAL SOCIAL
GENDER JUSTICE INTO OUR OWN
ANALYSIS. OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THAT WILL HIGHLIGHT THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA
FARMERS. CALIFORNIA JUST REAL
SECTOR AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
WHAT CALIFORNIA'S 35% OF OUR CAP
AND TRADE MONIES THAT ARE
DEVOTED TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND NOW THE
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S JUSTICE FORTY
TO INVEST 40% WILL WILL BRING TO
INDUSTRY. IN CALIFORNIA HOUSING
POLICY IS CLIMATE POLICY WE MAKE
THE LOWEST INCOME PEOPLE DRIVE
THE FURTHEST TO WORK IT IS
RACIALLY SOCIALLY AND GENDER
UNFAIR IT LIMITS OUR WORK FORCE
AND IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY WHERE.
INVESTING IN MIXED HOUSE MIXED
ABOUT MULTI UNIT HOUSING IN
TRADITIONAL SINGLE FAMILY
HOUSING AREAS IS A MOVEMENT
TOWARDS JUSTICE BOTH FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FOR THE CLIMATE
. A FINAL AREA IS THAT A KEY
INTO OUR LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT
ONLY DO THE RESEARCH FOR WHICH
WERE ALREADY A LEADER BUT SHOULD
BEGIN TO IMPLEMENT SUSTAINABLE
MATERIALS POLICIES AS WE HEARD
IN IN THE PRIOR TESTIMONY. THAT
WILL ENSURE THAT FOR BATTERY
MATERIALS FOR SOLAR MATERIALS
FOR ADVANCED VEHICLES WE SOURCE
SOCIALLY RACIALLY
ENVIRONMENTALLY JUST MATERIALS.
WE ALREADY KNOW THERE ARE MAJOR
AUTOMAT MANUFACTURERS FROM FORD
TO B. M. W. TO OTHERS
HIGHLIGHTING THIS HAVING THE
LARGEST VEHICLE MARKET UNITED
STATES CALIFORNIA. SETTING
STANDARDS IN THESE AREAS WILL
ACCELERATE THE PUSH TOWARDS
SUSTAINABLE- ACCESS TO LITHIUM
COBALT OTHER CRITICAL MATERIALS
YOU'LL OPEN THE MARKET JUST THE
WAY CALIFORNIA'S LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD. FINAL OPPORTUNITY AREA
AND THAT IS TO INVEST IN JUST
HER BEADED MINI GRIDS IN
PARTICULAR FOR RURAL AREAS AND
FOR UNDERSERVED INCORPORATED
AREAS- BUT EVEN FROM URBAN AREAS
MANY GRADES PROVIDE. RESILIENCE
THEY PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES TO
MEET DEMANDS WITHOUT THE
CHALLENGES OF WILDFIRES THEY
ALSO PROVIDE ECONOMIC JOBS IN
THE MOST UNDERSERVED AREAS. ANY
OR ALL OF THESE AREAS ARE RIGHT
FOR THE KINDS OF BOLD
OPPORTUNITIES I HIGHLIGHTED THE
BEGINNING AND I'D BE DELIGHTED
TO WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE DOWN
THE ROAD TO IMPLEMENT ANY OF
THESE THAT YOU LOOK AS AS PRIME
TARGETS FOR YOUR ACTION I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE TIME TO
SPEAK. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS OF THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR KAMAN I UNDERSTAND. I CAN
BE I THANK ALL THE PANELISTS
HAVE BEEN. PATIENT TO IN OUR
DIRECT THE QUESTION UNTIL AFTER
THE PRESENTATIONS BRIAN SO YOU
MAY HAVE TO LEAVE OF COURSE I DO
I HAVE A TWELVE O'CLOCK FEDERAL
TESTING. OKAY ALL RIGHT SO YOU
YOU'RE NOT AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS I CAN STAY FOR A BIT I
TOLD I'M NOT THE FIRST WITNESS
AND IT'S A THREE PM START SO IN
THE EAST COAST SO I DON'T MAKE
IT LATER OKAY. WITH THE OF THE-
INDULGENCE OF THE OTHER
PANELISTS TO IT DR CAM AND ANY
QUESTIONS FOR A- DOT KAMAN. IS
IDEA THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR YOUR PRESENTATION CAN YOU-
GO BACK AND REPEAT WHAT YOU SAID
OR YOUR STATEMENT ABOUT THE PC
AND SOLAR AND THE LACK OF TRUST.
YEP FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO THE PROPOSED DRAFT RULING
THAT WOULD HAVE TAXED SOLAR
RETROACTIVELY AND WOULD HAVE
ESSENTIALLY CLAWED BACK SOME OF
THE GAINS FROM SOLAR. HAS
ELEMENTS THAT MAKE ECONOMIC
SENSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE NET
METERING WERE- REGULATIONS NEED
TO BE UPDATED. BUT PUTTING A
BRAKE ON SOLAR WHICH IS
EFFECTIVELY WHAT THE P. YOU SEE
RULING WOULD HAVE DONE. WOULD
ESSENTIALLY BE AKIN TO KILLING
THE GOLDEN GOOSE IN THE SENSE OF
SOLAR HAS NOW BECOME FROM THE
MOST EXPENSIVE TECHNOLOGY
DECADES AGO TO THE LEAST
EXPENSIVE TODAY. IT'S THE AREA
WE WANT TO WE WANT TO REWARD THE
MOST DISTRIBUTED GENERATION.
FROM INDIVIDUAL HOMES TO PUBLIC
HOUSING PROJECTS TO INTEGRATING
SOLAR INTO SMALL AND MEDIUM
BUSINESSES ALL OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES NOT ONLY DEPLOYED
MORE SOLAR. BUT THEY- WITH
TODAY'S ECONOMICS THEY
FACILITATE THE INTERACTION OF
ENERGY STORAGE AND IN FACT THE
FASTEST GROWING COMBINATION OF
NEW ENERGY GENERATION IN
CALIFORNIA. IS DEPLOYMENT OF
INTEGRATED SOLAR PLUS STORAGE
TECHNOLOGIES. THAT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO MISS OUT ON OR SEND SIGNALS
TO THE PRIVATE SECTOR THAT WE
ARE NOT THE MOST OPEN THE MOST.
SOCIAL JUSTICE RACIALLY
PROGRESSIVE PLACE TO INSTALL THE
COUNTRY AND IN FACT LAST YEAR
WAS THE FIRST YEAR THE
CALIFORNIA. LET LOST THE TOP
SPOT IN THE IN THE MOST AMOUNT
OF DISTRIBUTED SOLAR DEPLOYED
TEXAS IS NOW AHEAD OF US AFTER.
FOR THE ENTIRE HISTORY OF SOLAR
WE BEING IN THE FIRST PLACE. AND
THAT THAT COST US JOBS AND THAT
ALSO COST US COMPANIES THAT
WOULD LOCATE HERE AND SO BY
HIGHLIGHTING THE FACT THAT THE
BATTLE WERE HAVING OVER THE P.
YOU SEE- THAT THAT THE P. YOU
SEE PROPOSED DECISION. IS ONE
THAT IS SENT A NEGATIVE SIGNAL
THE INDUSTRY ABOUT THE CLARITY
THAT CALIFORNIA IS THE FIRST
PLACE THEY SHOULD INVEST HAS
HEARD US ON THE JOBS BASIS AND
THAT'S REALLY THE BASIS FOR MY
COMMENT THERE. THERE IS ONE
ELEMENT OF THE POSE RULING THAT
I STAND STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF AND
THAT IS CARVING OUT A FUND. THAT
WOULD BE MANAGED BY A PUBLIC.
ASSEMBLY AND PRIVATE SECTOR
GROUP TO INVEST IN ENERGY
STORAGE FOR LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES. SO THAT WE DON'T.
LIKE MANY OTHER TECHNOLOGIES
HAVE THEM THE LAST COMMUNITIES
TO RECEIVE THE LATEST TECHNOLOGY
THAT'S ONE OF THE KEY AREAS THAT
I THINK NEEDS TO BE PRESERVED
BUT WE NEED TO FIND A WAY. TO
BRING THIS TOGETHER SO THAT. THE
PC CAN MOVE FORWARD UTILITIES
RECEIVE CREDIT FOR DISTRIBUTED
SOLAR WHICH RIGHT NOW THEY
ESSENTIALLY DO NOT RECEIVE- AND
TO MOVE THAT INDUSTRY EVEN AT A
HIGHER GEAR NOW THAT IT'S BECOME
SO LOW COST. THAT THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION. I'M NOT. I HAVE A
FOLLOW UP FOR YOU IN TERMS OF
HOW DO WE ADDRESS SOME OF THE
MOST- SOME OF THE CONCERNS
RELATED TO LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AS WE MOVE FORWARD TO FULLY
ATTAINING SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
HOPE TO ACHIEVE WHICH IS 1100%
RENEWABLE AND WE HAVE. A GOAL OF
TWENTY FORTY FIVE AND OFTEN WANT
TO MOVE FORWARD I REPRESENT A
COMMUNITY THAT IS SURROUNDED BY
FREEWAYS AND SO CLEAN AIR- YOU
KNOW BEING ABLE TO REDUCE OUR
ASK MARIE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
OUR CMMUNITY AND RENEWABLE
ENERGY IS CLEARLY THE DIRECTION
THAT WE SHOULD GO I AM HOWEVER-
GONNA PUT SOMETHING ON YOUR
RADAR AND I AND I HOPE THAT YOU
THOUGHT ABOUT THIS. AND THAT'S A
MAY TWENTY TWENTY ONE REPORT BY
THE P. YOU SEE BY AN INDEPENDENT
AUDITOR THEN THE REPORT IS
CALLED THE UTILITY COSTS AND
AFFORDABILITY OF THE GRID OF THE
FUTURE AND ON PAGE THIRTY IS
SIMPLY STATES THE EVALUATION
STUDY FOUND THAT AS COMPARED TO
THE GENERAL CALIFORNIA
POPULATION NAME CUSTOMERS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY OLDER LOCATED
IN HIGH INCOME AREAS LIKELY TO
OWN THEIR OWN HOME AND LESS
LIKELY TO LIVE IN A DIS AND LESS
LIKELY TO LIVE IN A DISTANT. A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
CONSEQUENTLY THE COST OF NUMBER
DISPROPORTIONATELY PAID BY
YOUNGER LESS WEALTHY AND MORE
DISADVANTAGED REPAIRS MANY OF
WHOM ARE RENTERS AND SO TO
ADDRESS ALL OF THESE CONCERNS
THAT YOU SEE IS CONSIDERING A
RESTRUCTURING OF NUMBER TO PUT-NO WHICH IS WHAT YOU ARE SAYING
THIS HAS DENTED THE TRUST. OF
THE SOLAR INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
WE ARE ALL CONCERNED WHAT WHAT
THE FUTURE LOOKS LIKE I
REPRESENT A DISTRICT THAT IS 20%
BELOW THE NATIONAL POVERTY LINE
WHY SHOULD LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND RENTERS PAY FOR THE
DIFFERENCE WHAT IS THE SOLUTION
THAT WE SHOULD BE CONSIDERING AN
EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT SOLAR IS
NOT JUST SOLELY FOR INDIVIDUALS
THAT OWN THEIR HOMES BUT WHAT
ARE THE INCENTIVES THAT WE
SHOULD BE CONSIDERING US WE AND
AS WE TRY TO. EXPAND THE GRID. I
WE TRY TO REDUCE CONSUMPTION
SOME FOSSIL FUELS. BUT THE COST
SHOULD NEVER BE ON THE BURDEN OF
LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND THE POOR
AND RENTERS WHAT IS YOUR-
RESPONSE IS THIS IS A GREAT
QUESTION THANKS FOR THANKS FOR
RAISING IT SO- THAT SECTION YOU
REFER TO WAS PARTIALLY BASED ON
A STUDY THAT MY LABORATORY DID
WITH GOOGLE. WHERE WE LOOKED AT
WHO HAD SOLAR ACROSS THE COUNTRY
. AND CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT ACROSS AN ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE OF INCOME FROM
FAMILIES JUST BELOW THE POVERTY
LINE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR FOR A FAMILY OF
FOUR WHICH OF COURSE IS NOT
AFFORDABLE IN CALIFORNIA. TO A
QUARTER MILLION. WHAT THE WHOLE
RANGE. WHITE MAJORITY
NEIGHBORHOODS WERE 50% MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE SOLAR. LET NECKS
IN AFRICAN AMERICAN
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE 5275% LESS
LIKELY TO HAVE SOLAR. FROM THE
LOWEST INCOME TO THE HIGHEST
INCOME AND I'D BE HAPPY TO SEND
THAT REPORT AFTERWARDS IF YOU IF
YOU LIKED IT IF ELECTED. TO TAKE
A LOOK AT IT. WHAT WE FOUND
UNFORTUNATELY WAS THAT MANY OF
THE POLICIES THAT WERE USED TO.
DEPLOY SOLAR. INVESTING IN SOME
SMALL COMPANIES INVESTING IN
SOME REAL ESTATE COMPANIES.
FOLLOWED THE OLD MODEL. OF
INVESTING IN. IN A LARGELY
CAUCASIAN DOMINATED COMPANIES.
AND THEY'VE DEPLOYED PRIMARILY A
AND LIKE COMMUNITIES. AND SO
FROM HOUSING COMPANIES TO SMALL
SCALE SOLAR WE REPEATED. THE
FAILED MODEL OF THE PAST WE ALSO
KNOW. THAT FICUS SCORES ARE USED
IN PRETORIA WAYS AGAINST
MINORITY COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND IN CALIFORNIA. AND
EVEN SOME POLICY IS ONE THAT I
HELPED DESIGN CALLED PACE
FINANCING. FROM A LATE LARGE
STUDY LOS ANGELES WE FOUND IT
WAS USED AS A PREDATORY TOOL
AGAINST A LOW INCOME. MINORITY
AN OLDER HOME OWNERS. SO THAT'S
A HORRIBLE LEGACY OF NOT MOVING
TO THE BENEFITS AND SO. I WOULD
SAY THERE ARE SEVERAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO ADDRESS WHAT
YOU SAID ONE IS. THE CALIFORNIA
DOES HAVE OUR CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS WHICH WILL NOT FUND ALL OF
THIS. BUT THERE ARE GREAT FIRST
LEVER. CALIFORNIA DEVOTES 35% OR
MORE OF THOSE FUNDS TO MINORITY
FENCE LINE. MOST EXPOSED
COMMUNITIES BUT THAT'S A FLOOR
NOT A CEILING- CENTER WHEN HE
WAS SENATOR- CENTER PART TIME-
KEVIN DE LEÓN HIGHLIGHTED THAT
THAT FLOOR WAS DESIGNED TO RISE.
THE FEDERAL NUMBER. BUT BASED ON
OUR TOTAL IS 40% OF FEDERAL
SPENDING CALIFORNIA COULD UP THE
FRACTION OF MONEY FROM THE CAP
AND TRADE. THAT IS DEVOTED TO
THESE FIRST PROJECTS IN LOW
INCOME AREAS LIKE IN YOUR
DISTRICT. AND ONE OF THE REAL
OPPORTUNITIES. IS TO A SO THE
SOAK SOLARGARDEN LAWS SO THAT
YOU NEED NOT BE A PROPERTY OWNER
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE. LOCAL STORES
SUCH AS GROCERY STORES HAVE
OFFRED SEVERAL TIMES TO HOST
SOLAR. AND THAT COULD BE USED TO
OFFSET UTILITY BILLS WHERE THAT
THE ARRANGEMENT WOULD BE A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN LAND OF
PROPERTY OWNERS AND THE RENTERS
TO SPLIT THE BENEFITS OF SOLAR
RISING IN USING THESE OFF SITE
LOCATIONS TO DO SO. THAT'S ONE
OF THE TOOLS THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE. THE SECOND ONE
IS TO LOOK AT THE MODEL THAT
LIFT HAS PILOTED BUT HASN'T
MOVED AGGRESSIVELY ENOUGH YET ON
AND THAT IS TO MAKE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. AVAILABLE FOR PURCHASE
OR FOR LEASE AT OR BELOW COST
THAT'S A NATURAL AREA FOR
CALIFORNIA TO SUBSIDIZE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES TO BE EXCESS EXCESS BY
LOW INCOME MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE TYING ELECTRIC
VEHICLES TO LOCAL GREEN
GENERATION IS ALSO WAY. TO DROP
THE LARGEST PART OF MOST
PEOPLE'S BILLS WHICH IS
TRANSPORTATION. SO I THINK THAT
THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE SAID
OF OPPORTUNITIES IS IN FACT
ARGUABLY OUR MOST EXCITING SET
BECAUSE THAT'S THE ONE WE'VE
SADLY DONE THE LEAST ON SO I
THINK THIS IS AN AREA WHERE CAN
A MENU OF. OF JUST TRANSITION
OPPORTUNITIES WOULD MOST
ACCELERATE THE CALIFORNIA'S
MOVEMENT BUT WOULD ALSO PUT THE
BENEFITS INTO THE LEAST OF THAT
HISTORICALLY DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST PARTS OF THE STATE. HI
MY NAME IS RICHARD THANK YOU FOR
THE INDULGENCE. THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CONVERSATION IS
INTERESTING IN AREAS WHERE YOU
ARE NOT A HOMEOWNER YOU DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO A GARAGE WHEN YOU
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO ACTUALLY
CREATE. THE PLUGIN FOR YOUR
VEHICLE SO IF WE ARE LOOKING AT-
RESIDENCY APARTMENTS. WHAT IS
THE WHAT IS THE INCENTIVE FOR
THE OWNER OF AN APARTMENT
COMPLEX TO BE ABLE TO PUT IN.
SOLAR FOR THE RENTERS- IN THAT
BUILDING YEAH I THINK THERE'S
TWO ASPECTS AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
TIED TOGETHER. THE FIRST IS THAT
AGAIN THESE BILLS THAT UPS THAT
HAVE BEEN WORKED ON THE SO
CALLED SOLAR GARDENS BILLS ARE
DESIGNED TO SPLIT THE INCENTIVE
THAT THE HOME OF THAT THE
PROPERTY OWNER GETS AN INCENTIVE
AS LONG AS- THE SAVINGS. BY
GOING TO ELECTRICITY ARE. PASSED
ON TO RENTERS IN THERE BILLS
THAT HAS. ISSUES THAT YOU CAN'T
DO IT ALL AT THE STATE LEVEL
THERE'S ALSO LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
JURISDICTION ASPECTS. BUT IT'S
ONE OF THE OPPORTUNITIES. THE
OTHER PART IS WHAT YOU
HIGHLIGHTED IN TERMS OF THE
EEVEE PART OF THAT STORY. I
CURRENTLY RUN A PROJECT FUNDED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. CALLED THE ECO BLOCK
AND IT TAKES A LOW INCOME FORTY
HOME AND APARTMENT BLOCK IN
OAKLAND. ELECTRIFY IS BY PUTTING
SOLAR ON THE ROOF BUT IT'S A
SHARED RESOURCES SO IT DOES NOT
POWER THE HOMES DIRECTLY. IT
GOES INTO A SHARED ENERGY
STORAGE FACILITY THAT POWERS THE
HOMES. POWERS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
EASY CHARGING IN THE REGULAR
STREET SIDE PARKING AREAS AND
THEN THE EXTRA POWER BEYOND THAT
IS THEN SOLD BACK TO P. JEANNIE.
THE EAGLE BLOCK IS AN EXAMPLE OF
A MIXED USE WHERE THERE ARE SOME
PROPERTY OWNERS ON THE BLOCK
IT'S IN THE FRUITVALE SECTION OF
OAKLAND. AND THERE ARE PERMANENT
BUILDINGS ON THE BLOCK AS WELL.
ALMOST EVERYONE WHO OWNS AN
EEVEE LARGELY THEM THE MORE
AFFLUENT WIDER. BOB PUBLISHED IN
CALIFORNIA. REPORTS THAT DID YOU
ALMOST ALL OF THEIR CHARGING AT
HOME. SO WITHOUT MAKING THAT
CHARGING AVAILABLE AT CONVENIENT. RACIAL DISPARITY THANKFULLY
THE GOVERNOR'S- A TEN BILLION
DOLLAR COMMITMENT TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES JUST RECENTLY ANNOUNCED
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY PUT THAT
MONEY BOTH TO MAKING EVEY
CHARGINGAVAILABLE WHERE RENTERS
LIVE AND ALSO TO SUBSIDIZING THE
PURCHASE OR LEASE OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS NOT MORE AFFLUENT
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
IS INTERESTING ESPECIALLY IN THE
RECOGNITION THAT LOW INCOME
FAMILIES ARE LOW INCOME AREAS IN
GENERAL DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
WHAT WE ARE CONSIDERING WILL BE
THE VERY NEAR FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA RIGHT MY DAD DRIVES A
OLD NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE TOYOTA
PICKUP. AND SO I THINK ABOUT
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE I THINK
ABOUT MY DAD WOULD DRIVE THIS
TRUCK HOW IS HE GOING TO ONE BE
ABLE TO AFFORD IN YOUR VEHICLE
TO WHERE IS HE GOING TO PLUG IT
IN AND MANY FAMILIES LIKE THAT
SO I'M CURIOUS IF THERE'S A WAY
THAT WE CAN LOOK AT THAT
POTENTIAL BUDGET PROPOSAL. AND
THINK OF IT- THREE CENSUS TRACTS
THE CENSUS CAN GIVE US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT WHERE ARE
THE AREAS THAT HAVE THE MOST
NEED WHERE THE AREAS AND WE
SHOULD POTENTIALLY FOCUS ON AND
HOW CAN WE CREATE EQUITY AND
THIS NEW CONVERSATION ABOUT
RENEWABLE ENERGY WHICH IS. I
THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT AND
MISSING PIECE IN THIS ENTIRE
PROCESS. THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THAT UP AND SO I'M GONNA GO BIT
OFF SCRIPT HERE- I HAVE A
FAVORITE POLICY BUT AGAIN IT'S
ONE FOR THE COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT
AND IT'S A FEE BASED POLICY. AND
THAT IS AS WE LOOK AT VEHICLES
AS A FUNCTION OF COST OR AS A
FUNCTION OF CARBON EMISSIONS. WE
ATTACH A FEE TO THOSE THAT WE
WANT TO DISCOURAGE AND WE
TRANSFER THAT TO THE PURCHASE BY
PEOPLE FOR IN AREAS WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE. AND THAT CAN BE
SIMPLY A POLICY WHERE YOU HAVE
KIND OF A SYMMETRIC WE TAX ON
ONE SIDE WE GIVE THE OTHER SIDE.
BUT THERE'S NO REASON WHY THAT
CAN'T BE BASED ON INCOME. SO THE
IDEA THAT WE COULD CRAFT A FEE
BAIT. TO ENCOURAGE ELECTRIC
VEHICLES. BUT TARGETED. YOU TOO
LOW INCOME MEMBERS OF OUR COVER
COMMUNITY. TO MY OWN ST UP MY
OWN OPINION MAKES A GREAT DEAL
OF SENSE AND IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT'S BEEN DISCUSSED IN THE
PAST. WE DID NOT ACT ON IT- I
THINK IT'S ONE OF THE TOOLS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO US RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WHERE IT'S BEEN TRIED
SUGGESTED IRELAND AND FRANCE AND
FRANCE IN THE BONUS MALUS
SYSTEM. IT'S BEEN VERY
EFFECTIVE. HOW MANY YOU CAN
TARGET AGAIN WITH THE ONE YOU
SENSE THIS TRACTOR AREAS ARE
PURELY INCOME. THOSE ARE ALL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE THERE ARE
NOT PROHIBITED. AND THANKFULLY
THE CAP AND TRADE MONEY. IS
FAIRLY UNRESTRICTED IN THIS AREA
BECAUSE OF THE REQUIREMENT FOR A
BI MENTAL JUSTICE SO THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD A POLICY
HERE. I SUSPECT EVERYONE AROUND
THE ROOM NOT EVERYONE WOULD BE
AS EXCITED ABOUT- THE FE BATES
AS I AM BUT IT'S ONE OF THE WAYS
THAT WE CAN MOVE THE MONEY MOST
DIRECTLY. AND THAT OF COURSE
FEEDBACK. BECAUSE THE MORE WE
PUSH FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES THE
MORE IT MAKES OUR CLEAN ENERGY
STANDARDS EFFECTIVE AND SO WE
GET AIR QUALITY BENEFITS. WE GET
JOBS BENEFITS WE ALSO PUSH MORE
FOR THE MANUFACTURING OF
VEHICLES. THE MEDIA MORE DIVERSE
RANGE OF NEEDS NOT JUST KIND OF.
TESLA'S IN AFFLUENT
NEIGHBORHOODS BUT WORKING
VEHICLES. THANK YOU- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR YES CENTER BACK UP
I'LL JUST KEEP IT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I. AGREE WITH WHAT YOU
SAID- I'M TO ASK ABOUT THE SAME
A MATERIALS CODE AND- WE CAN
TAKE IT OFF OR DO SOMETHING TO
IT. YOU CAN SHARE WITH US ON
THAT IDEA BECAUSE NOT WHEN I HAD
BEEN FAMILIAR WITH. YES ONE
THAT'S ACTUALLY STILL UNDER
UNDER DISCUSSION IN A VARIETY OF
AREAS MASSACHUSETTS IS LOOKING
AT IT- GERMANY AND FRANCE ARE
BOTH LOOKING AT IT. BUT THE IDEA
WOULD BE TO BUILD SOMETHING VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE HAVE IN THE
LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD. AND
THAT IS A GRAMS OF CO TWO
EMISSION PER MATERIAL IN THE
END. AND SO IF WE LOOK AT SOME
OF THE MOST DAMAGING ASPECTS OF
MINING FOR LITHIUM FOR COBALT.
AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND A
CARBON STANDARD. IS SOME OF THE
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE'VE
ALREADY WORKED THROUGH IN THE
STATE WITH THE L. CFS. THT
WOULD ALLOW US TO FIRST SOURCE
THE MORE SUSTAINABLE MATERIALS.
BUT THEN ALSO TO PUSH THE MINING
INDUSTRY AND THE LARGE OEMS THE
AUTO MANUFACTURERS. TO ALSO
SOURCE THOSE MORE SUSTAINABLE
MATERIALS. AND THAT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT BOTH FITS INTO
OUR CODE IT FITS INTO THE
RECYCLING LAWS WE ALREADY USE
WHERE- LOOK OF CELL PHONES AND
LAPTOPS PURCHASED IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE A RECYCLING FEE BUILT IN.
BUT WE COULD NOW DO THIS AROUND
CARBON. AND SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
WE KNOW THAT MANY OF THE
MATERIALS IN THE DEVICES WE USE
ALL THE TIME. COME FROM CONFLICT
AREAS IN THE CONGO AND ELSEWHERE
WHERE I WORK- BUT SOME.
STANDARDS. THAT REQUIRE THESE TO
BE. BETTER ON THE CLIMB HUMAN
BASIS WOULD BE SOME THAT WOULD
FIT WELL INTO CALIFORNIA'S-
OVERALL PLAN SO THAT'S THAT'S
THE THAT'S THE- START I WOULD.
RECOMMEND ON THAT. THANK YOU.
THE QUESTIONS. OKAY QUICK
QUESTION IF YOU STILL ARE YOU
OKAY WITH YEAH I KNOW COULD
HURT- SO I MEAN I YOUR YOUR FEE
BAIT IDEA I ACTUALLY I. WAS
WORKING ON A CARBON FEE AND
DIVIDEND- A PER PROPOSAL BUT-
YOU KNOW BE A GIVEN THE- THE
WARRANT IN UKRAINE AND IN THE
SKYROCKETING GAS PRICES MEAN.
DID YOU KNOW THAT AND SO THAT
SEEMS TO BE THAT YOU KNOW OF
THIS THEME THAT THAT I'M HEARING
ON THIS CARDIO AND OTHERS HAVE
RAISED I MEAN. WE HAVE THESE YOU
KNOW THESE ASPIRATIONS TO TAKE
BOLD ACTION TO ADVANCE CLIMATE
AGENDA AND YET. YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE REALITIES
OF PEOPLE THAT. YOU KNOW- STILL
DRIVING THEIR NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE TRUCK OR OR OR OR FOLKS
THAT ARE. USING DIESEL TRACTORS
I MEAN IT'S. AND ANY ANY
THOUGHTS ON. YEAH I THINK IT'S
ACTUALLY IT'S TIED INTO THE SAME
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE BOTH
THESE QUESTIONS I MEAN RIGHT NOW
WITH THE HIGH PRICES DUE TO
PRICE GOUGING AND RESTRICTED
SUPPLY- DUE TO THE WAR IN
UKRAINE. IT'S NOW FIFTY DOLLARS
OR MORE TO DRIVE TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILES IN AN S. U. V. WHERE
IS AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE IT'S ON
THE ORDER OF TEN DOLLARS. SO
THERE IS A SOCIAL ECONOMIC
INJUSTICE IN NOT INNOVATING MORE
IN THESE AREAS. CALIFORNIA IS
THE BIGGEST VEHICLE MARC IN THE
COUNTRY. IS THE BIGGEST DRIVER
IN DEMAND WHEN PRESIDENT BIDEN
GOT INTO AN F. ONE FIFTY
LIGHTNING A MIDDLE YEAR HIGH AND
EXPENSIVE PICKUP TRUCK. HE WAS
SENDING A VERY CRITICAL MESSAGE.
AND THEN RECENT AGREEMENTS TO
ALLOW POWERING OF HOMES. FROM
ELECTRIC VEHICLES IS A START IN
THE SO CALLED VEHICLE TO GRID SO
THERE'S A LONG TERM STRATEGY
THAT WILL BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS NOT JUST THE MOST
AFFLUENT. BUT IN THE SHORT TERM.
WITH BRIGHT WITH GAS PRICES IN
CALIFORNIA NOW CLIMBING TOWARD
SIX DOLLARS A MORE GALLON. OUR
STRATEGY IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE
TIED INTO ADDITIONAL SHORT TERM
SUPPLY NOT ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT
IN LONG TERM OIL AND GAS. BUT IN
WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO RELEASE MORE
PETROLEUM FROM THE STURGE
PETROLEUM RESERVE. AND TO FIND
OPPORTUNITIES SO THAT IN THE
MEDIUM TERM. WE CAN GET THE AUTO
MANUFACTURERS TO FOCUS MORE ON
THE VEHICLES THAT WE SEE AS
CRITICAL AND AGAIN WE HEARD FROM
SEVERAL WITNESSES CALIFORNIA'S
CRITICAL- AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTION IS ALSO A HUGE
DEMAND. THAT'S NOT GOING TO FIX
THE PROBLEM TOMORROW MORNING BUT
WE ARE LIKELY TO SEE
UNFORTUNATELY YOU MORE CRISES
LIKE UKRAINE NOT LESS OVERTIME
AS RESOURCES GET FOUGHT OVER IN
DIFFERENT WAYS. AND SO THAT
TRANSITION STRATEGY IS ONE THAT
CAN IF WE CAN REVERSE THIS BIAS
TOWARDS THE RICHEST FIRST WHICH
IS REALLY WHAT CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE LAWS ALL ABOUT. SB
THIRTY TWO WOULD NOT HAVE PASSED
WITHOUT STRONG SUPPORT. FROM THE
RAMAGE ESTES COMMUNITY THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED TO. FOR MMHM- IT
ONE OF THE OTHER RECOMMENDATIONS
IS TO ACCELERATE THE TIME LINES
FOR OFFSHORE WIND- MR GARCIA
RATE RAISE THIS POINT EARLIER WE
ARE AT A CONFERENCE LAST WEEK-
WHERE. YOU KNOW THEY THEY THEY
TALKED ABOUT- YOU KNOW HOW IT
THERE THERE THERE IS. LIKE AFTER
WHEN COMPANIES WERE WERE SAYING
THAT THEY'RE READY TO BOOK IT TO
HAVE PROJECTS TO COME ONLINE AND
YET IT TAKES LIKE LIKE UP TO TEN
YEARS TO GET THE TRANSMISSION
GRID- HOOK UP- AND HOW DO WE
ACCELERATE THAT. SO THERE'S NO
UNFORTUNATELY ESY ANSWER THIS
ONE THE PACK WAVE. WAVE TEST
SITE IN SOUTHERN OREGON IS AN
EXAMPLE OF HAVING HOOK UPS IN
PLACE. THE ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY HUMBOLDT BAY WAS CHOSEN. AS
ONE OF OUR TWO EARLY BLOCKS IS
BECAUSE THE TRANSMISSION
CAPACITY WHILE NOT FULLY BUILT
WAS PLANNED FOR THE NUCLEAR
IRONICALLY FOR THE NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT IT WAS THAT WAS STOP
DECADES AGO. SO THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES TO TIE THAT IN.
ENVIRONMENTAL ASSESSMENTS ARE
CRITICAL BUT- ALMOST EVERYONE I
TALKED WITH THERE ARE SOME
EXCEPTIONS BELIEVES THAT. FROM
OFF SHORE TO SHORE CONNECTIONS
IS THE MOST EFFICIENT- NEW
TRANSMISSION LINES TO PUT IN-
ENVIRONMENT FISH ALL HAVE RIGHTS
BUT OUR ABILITY TO WORK THE
JUSTICE ANGLES AND YOU DO THE
EIA IS. LARGELY BECAUSE CHINA
AND EUROPE ARE SO FAR AHEAD OF
US THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT GOALS
LIKE FIFTY AND SIXTY GIGAWATTS.
WHEREAS WE HAVE ZERO IN PLACE
RIGHT NOW SO THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CATCH UP. IS A FAIRLY BORING ONE
IN THE SENSE THAT WE WON'T CATCH
UP BY DOING STUDY AFTER STUDY WE
NEED HARDWARE IN THE WATER.
BECAUSE THE ONLY WAY YOU LEARN
WHAT WORKS BEST FOR COMMUNITIES
THE ONLY WAY YOU BRING IN THE
JOBS COMPONENTS IS TO GET SOME
INITIAL OFFSHORE TURBINES AND SO
GETTING EVEN VERY SMALL OFFSHORE
WIND FARMS. FIXED AND THEN THE
HEART MORE DIFFICULT FLOATING
ONES. IS THE BEST IT IS THE BEST
ANALYTICS AND AGAIN IT BEATS ANY
MODEL THAT I COULD BUILD OR
ANYONE ELSE COULD BUILD BECAUSE
WE SIMPLY NEED TO SEE THOSE IN
THE GROUND TO LEARN. WHAT WORKS
AND WHAT DOESN'T THANKFULLY WE
HAVE A GREAT RESOURCE. IT DID IF
I HEARD YOU RIGHT AND SO WE ARE
YOU SUGGESTING THE RIGHT CITING
AS WELL AS WHAT SEEK WITH
STREAMLINING I WOULD I WOULD
YEAH I WOULD DO INITIAL LINES TO
BOTH THE MORO BAY SITE AND THE
HUMBOLDT BAY ARE QUITE GOOD
INITIAL SITES. I WOULD START
WITH SMALL PILOT PROJECTS A FEW
TURBINES. AND THEN I WOULD BUILD
OUT FROM THERE- AND AGAIN THE
IDEA THAT WE COULD BE AT TEN
GIGAWATTS OF OFFSHORE WIND BY
THE END OF THIS DECADE AND I'VE
SEEN ESTIMATES FROM DIFFERENT
GROUPS MIGHT MY LABS MORE
AGGRESSIVE OTHERS TALK ABOUT
THREE GIGAWATTS. WE CAN GET
TOWARDS THAT TEN WORSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A QUARTER OR MORE
OF CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY NOT JUST
ELECTRICITY BUT GREEN HYDROGEN
TO. BY THE END OF THIS DECADE
COMING FROM SECTOR THAT DOES NOT
EXIST TODAY. AND IT'S THE ONE
THAT THE DEPART THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR. LOOKS AT AS
THE LARGEST POTENTIAL NEW JOB
CREATING INDUSTRY OF ANY ENERGY
SECTOR IN THE COUNTRY PERIOD
FULL STOP NO FOOTNOTE. THAT'S A
REAL OPPORTUNITY TO INVEST IN
CALIFORNIA WORKERS. THANK YOU
SEE NO YES- IS HOW DO THAN
CENTER SKINNER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND TRUST ME WHEN I SAY I
WANT TO PERSONALLY ALSO REACH
OUT TO YOU AND I KNOW YOU HAVE
TO GO TO HEAR OTHER- APPOINTMENT
I REALIZE THE TIME TO WE HAVE TO
CATCH A FLIGHT TO GO BACK HOME
I'M A BIG SUPPORTER OF ROOFTOP
SOLAR I'M BUT MOST OF FROM LOS
ANGELES. SO OUR WEATHER IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THE REST OF THE
STATE I'M ALSO A HUGE SUPPORTER
OF THE GREEN NEW DEAL AND THE
PILLARS OF THE GREEN NEW DEAL
WHICH INCLUDE THE JUST
TRANSITION OF WORKERS ENSURE
ENSURING THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
LEAVING PEOPLE BEHIND US WE TRY
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH WHAT WITH
OUR FUTURE LOOKS LIKE. IN A
CONVERSATION THAT I HAD WITH A
COLLEAGUE WHO LIVES BY THE
REDWOODS THE CONVERSATION ON
ROOFTOP SOLAR WAS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT TO SIMPLY BECAUSE SOME
MIGHT DOESN'T GET TO THE ROOFTOP
SOLAR AS MUCH AS YOU KNOW LOS
ANGELES AND THAT REALLY MADE ME
THINK ABOUT. WHAT WE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT IS A DIVERSE RENEWABLE
ENERGY PORTFOLIO SO WHAT DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE AND WHAT ARE THE
COSTS RELATED TO EACH OF THESE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF METHODS HAVE
YOU DONE OR DO YOU HAVE
INFORMATION ON LIKE A COST
COMPARISON ANALYSIS WHEN IT
COMES TO WHAT THAT ACTUALLY
LOOKS LIKE FOR- CARBON
REDUCTIONS THROUGH ROOFTOP SOLAR
VERSES OTHER YOU KNOW OTHER
APPROACHES. SUCH A LONGER%
CONVERSATION I'D FOLLOW UP AND
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU AFTERWARDS
BUT BOTH MY LABORATORY AND GREAT
AND GREAT GREAT ALTERNATIVES
USED TO BE CALLED BASE TO HEAR
AND- IT BUT BASS NO CALIFORNIA
AND TO THE SOCIAL JUSTICE ENERGY
LAB AT UCLA RUN BY PROFESSOR
STEPHANIE PINTLE. THOSE ARE ALL
LOOKED AT THIS I USED TO LIVE IN
AN APARTMENT IN NEWIN WEST
HOLLYWOOD ON FAIRFAX AND WE HAD
THESE VERY FOGGY LONG MORNINGS
THAT'S WHERE THIS TRADE OFF
BETWEEN SOME COLLECTIVE SOLAR
SUCH AS THE ON THE SURFACE ON ON
THE ROOF OF SAFEWAY OR RALPHS
GROCERY STORES SHARED BY THE
COMMUNITY IS AN EXCELLENT WAY TO
MOVE AHEAD BECAUSE THOSE LARGER
REYES. USED TO BE SIGNIFICANTLY
CHEAPER BUT AS. THE PRICES DROP
AND DROP FOR SOLAR. THE RALPH.
SOLAR POWER IS REALLY NO LONGER
THE RATE LIMITING COST STEP IT'S
THE INTEGRATION IT'S THE WORK
WITH UTILITY OR THE MUD
DEPENDING WHERE ONE'S WORKING
AND IT'S THERE WHERE THE LOCAL
RESTRICTIONS REALLY MATTERS BUT
IT'S ALSO THERE WHERE THE JOBS
BENEFITS CAN BE THE HIGHEST
BECAUSE ONE IRONY OF SMALL SCALE
DISTRIBUTED ROOFTOP SOLAR IS
THAT JUST MORE JOBS PER DOLLAR
PER MEGAWATT SO YOU KIND OF GOT
A BIT OF A BALANCE THERE AND I
THINK THAT'S A PLACE WHERE. ALL
OF THE ABOVE FOR SOLAR BUT ALSO
FOR LOCALLY DEPLOYED STORAGE
ENDS UP BEING A REAL WIN AT THE
COMMUNITY LEVEL. SANDERS CAN.
THANK YOU CHAIR I KNOW I'VE
THANK YOU FIRST CAME IN FOR-
COMING AND SHARING YOUR
THOUGHTS- A COUPLE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS- I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR- ELABORATION ON
THE YOU KNOW THE WAY YOU FEEL
MIGHT BE THE WEAKNESSES OF THE
PC'S- PENDING DECISION AND I
WONDERED IF YOU COULD TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE ROLE
YOU MENTIONED MICRO GRIDS. AND
WHILE THE STATE HAS NOT YET AND
I THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE BUT WE
HAVE NOT YET- OPENED UP FOR
PLANNED FOR THAT ABILITY OF MY
GROUP GRIDS TO HELP US ACHIEVE
OUR- STABILITY ON THE GRID IN
OUR RESILIENCY AND I OF COURSE
ROOFTOP SOLAR WITH STORAGE AND
THAT COULD BE ROOFTOP SOLAR ON
COMMERCIAL PUBLIC FACILITIES AS
WELL AS RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES
COULD PLAY OR NOT ONLY COULD IS
ESSENTIAL TO A TO A MARGARET- IN
MY ONE OF MY OBJECTIONS TO THE
PENDING DECISION WAS EXACTLY THE
POINT THAT COULD PRECLUDE OUR
ABILITY. WHICH I FEEL WE NEED TO
EXPLORE NOT ONLY FOR GRID
STABILITY BUT ALSO FOR- WE HAVE
TO DO POWER OUTAGES AT TIMES
WHETHER AS WILDFIRE OTHER
REASONS AND ARE BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THE GRID IS NOW YOU KNOW OUR
DAD IS NOW DESIGN THEY HAVE TO
BE IN LARGE AREAS VERSUS MORE
TARGETED AND. A MICROGRID WOULD
PRESERVE. I PLACE TO HAVE THEIR
NEED POWER THAT OTHER THAT
TURNED SO WOULDYOU MIND IF YOU
BRIEFLY- ON THE BUT FINE MY
OTHER. IS AROUND YOUR SENSE OF
HOW HOW QUICKLY. GREEN HYDROGEN
MIGHT BE ACTUALLY COMMERCIALLY
VIABLE IN FOR AND I AND I AM
WITHOUT PURCHASING GREEN
HYDROGEN THE Y. FEEL THAT THERE
ARE PROBABLY CERTAIN USES THAT
WOULD BE FAR MORE. A BENEFICIAL
TO US YOU KNOW LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
IN HEAVY DUTY LONG LONG. PAUL
VEHICLE- TRUCKS AND GOODS
MOVEMENT HOWEVER. PART OF THE
ISSUE IS YOU KNOW WHAT BOTH WHAT
WE NEED TO DO TO HELP IT. COME
TO BE COMMERCIALLY VIABLE AND
THEN HOW SOON DO YOU THINK IT
WOULD BE AND I'M TALKING
GRIGNARD. YEAH WELL ACTUALLY THE
ENERGY INNOVATION MODEL HAS A
REALLY IMPORTANT SECTION ON
LEADING OPPORTUNITIES FOR GREEN
HYDROGEN. AGAIN THE MORE WE
BUILD OUT OFFSHORE WIND THE MORE
WE GET THAT UNGIBLE SUPPLIED
BECAUSE THEY CAN SELL LIKE
TRICITY WENT PRICES HIGH
HYDROGEN WHEN THE PRICE OF
ELECTRICITY IS LOW. BUT BUILDING
OUT SOME INDUSTRIAL CLUSTERS IS
THE MODEL THAT BOTH THE E. U.
AND THE U. K. HAVE ADOPTED
FIRST. LONG BEACH IS A NATURAL
PLACE TO DO IT PORT OF OAKLAND
IS A NATURAL PLACE TO DO IT SAN
DIEGO TO DO BOTH INDUSTRY AND
THE MILITARY ARE PLACES WHERE
FIX DEMANDS REALLY HELP- IN THIS
WILL TIE BACK TO THE GREEN
CEMENT QUESTIONS AS WELL BECAUSE
THEY WERE GOING TO BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE WE WANT TO DO
THAT AND IS YOUR CARBON WAY. SO
WE DO NOT HAVE THE CURRENT
DEMAND FOR THAT HYDROGEN BUT
THIS IS A CASE WHERE CALIFORNIA
CAN REALLY CREATE THAT SO I
THINK THERE'S A PLACE WHERE
AGAIN THE TWO OTHER- PANELISTS.
HAVE SOME VERY SPECIFIC POINTS
FOR THOSE TO BE THE THREE HUBS
THAT I WOULD RECOMMEND FOR
REGIONAL AND THEY HAPPEN TO BE
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS THE STATE
WHICH IS CONVENIENT. SO WE WOULD
BUILD OUT SOME GREEN HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND REWARD USE.
AND THE BEST WAY TO REWARD USE
IS TO GO BACK TO THE SOCIAL COST
OF CARBON. BECAUSE IF WE WERE
UTILIZING A SOCIAL COST OF
CARBON HEIGHT WHICH IS HIGHER
THAN THE MARKET PRICE. WE WILL
BE REWARDING THAT GREEN HYDROGEN
EXACTLY IN THOSE IN THOSE
CENTERS SO I AGREE I AGREE WITH
YOU ON THAT ONE ON THE MICROGRID
STORE I COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU
MORE AND IN FACT. THE GLOBAL
PICTURE HAS MOVED ON SO MY DAY
JOB RIGHT NOW IS NOT AT UC
BERKELEY WHERE I'M PROFESSOR BUT
I'M THE ENERGY ADVISER FOR U. S.
AGENCY FOR NATIONAL DEVELOPMENT
THE BY THE MINISTRATION. WE ARE
NOW SEEING SO CALLED METRO GRIDS
. MEETING MOBILE LARGE THAN WE
MEGA. MAKER GRADES BEING BUILT
AROUND THE WORLD. FROM RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN AFRICA TO
COMMUNITIES IN EUROPE- IN
SOUTHEAST ASIA. THE ABILITY TO
BUILD MUCH LARGER MICRO GRIDS
NOW. PROVIDES MANY MORE PEOPLE
LIGHT INDUSTRY BUSINESS WITH.
CLEAN RELIABLE POWER. AND IF WE
REWARD. THE UTILITIES THE I'LL
USE. FOR TYING THOSE IN AS
OPPOSED TO PUNISHING THEM WHICH
HAS BEEN THEIR PERCEPTION ON HOW
WE PUSH THIS PRODUCT. THIS
PROCESS FORWARD. I ACTUALLY
THINK THERE'S A PATHWAY IN FRONT
OF THE P. U. C. TO ENABLE. MANY
GRIDS I'M A CALL THE NEWS METRO
GRIDS BUT TO DO SO IN A WAY THAT
REALLY BENEFITS. LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES NOT JUST TO AIR
QUALITY. BUT THROUGH JOBS AND
THROUGH THE REBUILD A VERY AS WE
MOST NEED TO DO IT AND AGAIN
THOSE PORT HUBS RUBY WOULD BE MY
RECOMMENDED STARTING POINTS. SO
I JUST I REALLY WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE I AM NOW PROBABLY AT A
POINT WHEN I MET A GIRL IN MY
CAR AND THEY GET ON MY-
TESTIMONY BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL I. LOOK FORWARD TO
FOLLOWING UP AND I'LL JUST LEAVE
SOME BUSINESS CARDS IF ANYBODY
WANTS TO. RESOLVE MY THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK THANK
A DOCTOR THEM. ALL RIGHT- THANK
YOU SO MUCH TO THE OTHER
PANELISTS. THAT HAVE BEEN
PATIENTLY WAITING TO. ANY ANY.
THE QUESTIONS FOR OUR THE
PANELISTS CENTER SKINNER. YES I
WANTED TO ASK A QUICK QUESTION I
HAVE TO LEAVE MYSELF FALL TO
SPREAD ON TWO MISTER. REGARDING
THE- ROSS. EMISSIONS SOME- WE-
MY COLLEAGUE SENATOR BECKER
ALREADY- HAD A SUCCESSFUL LOTS A
SUCCESSFUL BILL THAT'S NOW
SIGNED INTO LAW IN EFFECT THAT
WOULD BRING DOWN THE- ENERGY
INPUT- EMISSIONS RELATED TO
CEMENT AND CALLS FOR CEMENT OVER
ALL PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA.
TOO GPO KEEPING GIVE THE EXACT
GOAL BUT BUT IN BEING ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THAT THE CEMENT INDUSTRY
WILL HAVE TO DEAL WITH ITS
PROCESS EMISSIONS SO I HAVE A
BILL THAT I'VE INTRODUCED THIS
YEAR TO ALLOW FOR SOME PILOT
PROJECTS TO- CAPTURE THE PROCESS
EMISSIONS AND STORE THEM
GEOLOGICALLY. AND I WONDERED IF
YOU WANTED TO COMMENT EITHER ON
THE SWITCHERS SETS THE
FEASIBILITY OF THAT GEOLOGIC
STORAGE WORK THERE'S ANOTHER IF
THERE'S SOME OTHER THING THAT WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT. IN ORDER
TO DEAL WITH THE PROCESS
EMISSIONS FROM CEMENT. YEAH SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO THANK BOTH YOU AND SENATOR
RECORD FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. IT'S REALLY
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT- AS YOU
CORRECTLY POINT OUT- THE REASON
WHY- THE CEMENT INDUSTRY IS IN
MY OPINION THAT THE CORRECT
PLACE TO START. WITH ANY
ACTIVITY AROUND CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE IS BECAUSE OF THOSE
PROCESS EMISSIONS. THERE ARE
IDEAS OUT THERE FOR HOW WE CAN.
ROUTE ELIMINATE THOSE PROCESS
EMISSIONS BY WITHOUT THE USE OF
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE BUT
FRANKLY. I WOULD CHARACTERIZE
THEM AS AT THE LABORATORY STATE
. WELL SOME OF THEM ARE THE
LABORATORY STATE SOME OF THEM
ARE ONLY AVAILABLE AT VERY SMALL
SCALES SO THEY COULD NOT MEET IN
A BALK WAY OUR NEED FOR. CEMENT
AND CONCRETE. SO I THINK THAT
THAT IS A VERY REASONABLE
APPROACH. I ALSO THINK THAT IT
SHOULD BE COUPLED WITH THINGS
THAT- DO NOT REQUIRE THE SAME
LEVEL OF A NEW TECHNOLOGY AND
CAPITAL INVESTMENT LIKE US
CHANGING. CODES AND STANDARDS
AND SPECIFICATIONS THROUGH
CALTRANS TO INCENTIVIZE THE USE
OF LOS AMEND CONCRETES AND LOW
CLINKER CEMENTS. BOTH OF WHICH
CAN REDUCE GREENHOUSE THE
GREENHOUSE GAS INTENSITY OF
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
IMMEDIATELY AND WITHOUT MUCH
TECH WITHOUT ANY TECHNOLOGICAL
RISK IN MANY CASES AND OFTEN AT
A COST SAVINGS. WE WANT TO TAKE
IN ALL OF THE ABOVE APPROACH BUT
CERTAINLY THIS IS THE RIGHT
PLACE TO START WITH- OFF ANY
ACTIVITY AND CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE. THANK YOU AND- I DIDN'T
TEND TO DO THAT AT ONE POINT
FIVE. TO BE HONEST-
UNFORTUNATELY EVEN REMEMBER WHAT
THE DISPOSITION WHETHER IT NEVER
GOT ANYWHERE WHETHER ALTRANS
TWO THOUSAND IMPLEMENTED BUT IT
IS A VERY. THAT ISSUE IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE YEAHWE ARE
THE LARGEST USERS OF THE CEMENT
AND IF WE DON'T. IF WE THE STATE
OR NOT. DRIVING THE STANDARDS
FOR THE AGGREGATE TO BE ABSENT
OF SUCH. BE RECYCLED CONTENT
OTHERS THE AGGREGATE TO BE SUCH
THAT IT IS. PARDON LOWER CARBON
. AND IT'S PROCESSING MEASURE
THERE WERE BEING PRETTY. YES THE
REALLY IS. FINANCE WHO WAS A
THANK YOU THAT BILL THIS YEAR ON
THE- WE PUT A BY CLEAN. YEAH
THANK YOU THAT THAT'S GREAT.
HAVE A QUESTION I'M SURE I'LL
JUST FIRST WELL THANK YOU THE
OTHER PRESENTATIONS WERE
EXCELLENT- YES THINK HIGHLY
CEMENTED CENTER SKINNER SAID
WE'RE VERY FOCUSED ON IT AND- I
THINK IF WE CAN AUGMENT THAT WE
ARE WITH THOSE THAT THE BILL WE
PASSED THE FIRST BILL- AND
ACTUALLY FIRST REALLY BIG
CALIFORNIA AND CENTER MARKET
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI
PRESENTED IN THE- ASSEMBLY THAT-
THAT. FIRST ACCIDENT AS YOUR
TARGET FOR ANY SEGMENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY SO WE DO NOT
HAVE A NET ZERO TARGET ACTUALLY
BUILT IN- A BORDER CARBON.
ESCENARIO NO CAR HAS TO
IMPLEMENT THAT- BUT THAT WE
ACTUALLY PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
YOUR SUPPORT PART OF WHAT YOU
WERE SAYING TO WRITE IS TO WE
WANT OF COURSE NOT TO DRIVE
THESE DROPS COMPLETELY OUT OF
STATE. IT'S TO ACTUALLY MAKE
CHANGES THAT AFFECT THE GLOBAL
MARKETS ALTERNATELY- I YOU KNOW
SO FOR- DR BUSH'S THINK OF OVER
LIKE TO. HAVE THAT. WHICH A
COUPLE QUICK QUESTIONS TO SET
THAT- WE HAVE TO MORE THAN- FAR
PROGRESS TO ME OUR GOALS IS THAT
WE- THAT'S CORRECT BASED ON-
COMPARED TO THE FIVE YEAR TRENDS
WHICH WORKS OUT TO I THINK FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION METRIC TONS
PER YEAR- OF COURSE IT WILL CALL
AT FIVE AND THEN IF I'M
REMEMBERING THE SLIDE CORRECTLY.
A STRAIGHT LINE PATH TO. TWO
TWENTY THIRTY WHAT WOULD REQUIRE
AN AVERAGE REDUCTION OF SIXTEEN
MM CHIEF PER YEAR ARE MILLION
METRIC TONS. YES THEY SHOULD
GIVE US ALL PAUSE YOUR CHANGES
TO HIT OUR OWN CURRENT GOAL IS
NOT ONLY TO. HAVE ADDITIONAL-
AMBITION WE'VE HAD OUR OWN GOALS
HAVE TO TRIPLE OUR PROGRESS JUST
TO HAVE HER OWN GOALS THAT'S
RIGHT. YEAH YEAH I THINK THAT'S
JUST REALLY OPTIONS ARE
COLLEAGUES REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT- AND I THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THAT
MESSAGE OUT THE MEASURE GOVERNOR
ACTUALLY CREATES IT PROBABLY-
YEAH AND AGAIN WE HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY SURPLUS WE HAVE TO
DO THAT APPRECIATE YOUR OTHER.
EXAMPLES OF THE AT THE VERY TAX
WE DON'T EIGHTY NINE PERCENT.
AND YOUR CA NINETY THOUSAND
MOTOR VEHICLE JOBS A LOT OF BEEN
CREATED- INSTANCE THE PRE EVEY
ERROR IS THAT CORRECT. NOT
KNOWING FRACTURING- COMPARED TO
THE SO THE NEW ME THE GM TOYOTA
PLANT AND- IN THAT USED TO BE A
FREE MY CLOTHES DOWN IN TWENTY
TEN. AND IF YOU LOOK AT. THE
MUGGED ON OCT MANUFACTURING JOBS
BEFORE THEN THEY WERE NEVER MORE
THAN NINE THOUSAND AND SO NOW
WE'RE OVER NINETEEN THOUSAND SO
WE'RE WE'RE DOUBLE THE- HE AB
THIRTY TWO LEVEL IF YOU WORK
WELL OR OR- DOUBLE THE LEVEL
BEFORE EVEY MANUFACTURING-
STARTED IN CALIFORNIA. MMHM JEFF
AND THAT'S BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS DATA AND I'M HAPPY TO
SHARE THE- LOOK THE CODE IT
CETERA. WELL THAT'S IT YEAH GET
APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS A GREAT
STEP THAT WE SHOULD BE USING AND
THE- THE POLICY SIMULATOR I
SHOULD LOOK FOR TO. INTERESTS
AND HER COLLEAGUES AS WELL.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAY ON THE FREE
ALLOCATIONS- THAT THIS IS A HUGE
ISSUE WITH UNDERMINING OUR
CAPTURE MARKET CAN YOU SPEAK
MORE ABOUT THAT. YES WELL ALSO
THE SURPLUS SUPPLY OF ALLOWANCES
THAT HAVE BEEN BANK BUT- ONE OF
THE REASONS THE EUROPEAN UNION
IS MOVING TOWARDS THE BORDER
CARBON ADJUSTMENT MECHANISM
MECHANISM IS THEY'VE REALIZED
THAT. ANY FREE ALLOCATION- OVER
THE LONG RUN HAS SOME CONNECTION
TO- TURNS OUT TO BE A SUBSIDY
FOR EXISTING PRODUCTION AND SO
IT IT IT ENDS UP. UNDERMINING
THE PRICE SIGNAL IF THERE'S ANY
FREE ALLOCATION AND- SO THAT-
YOU KNOW. I THINK THERE'S
INCREASING RECOGNITION THAT THE
CARBON PRICES BEST A SWEEPING UP
US. A SHORT RUN LOW COST SUPPLY
PRODUCTIONS AND NOT NECESSARILY
INCENTIVIZING THE INVESTMENTS.
WE NEED MADE. SO ANY ADVICE FOR
US IN IN OUR CARBON MARKETS.
WELL I GUESS GIVEN- YOU KNOW
AFFORDABILITY CONCERNS IN THE
INEVITABILITY. OF COST PASSED
THROUGH IT AND YOU CAN DEAL WITH
THAT BY USING THE OPTION REVENUE
UP I'M MORE INCLINED TO POINT
OUT SOME OF THE DIRECT SECTOR
STANDARDS WHICH ARE ACTUALLY CAN
HAVE MARKET MECHANISM LIKE-
ATTRIBUTES I THINK CALIFORNIA IS
BLOWN APART THE AYE THE SORT OF
FALSE BINARY. COMMANDED CONTROL
VERSES MARKETS. THE DICHOTOMY IF
YOU WILL SO YOU KNOW IN THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD WE HAVE A
TRADING MECHANISM WITH MANY OF
OUR- MANY OF OUR- OUR SECTOR
POLICIES HAVE UP. FLEXIBILITY
THAT ALLOWS A LEAST COST OF
SOLUTIONS SO- I THINK YOU KNOW
THE OF INDUSTRIAL. STANDARD FOR
HEAT OF SUMMER DEAR COOK- CEMENT
POLICY. IS THE DIRECTION I'D BE
MORE INCLINED TO GO OTHERWISE-
YOU KNOW IT'S ADJUSTMENTS EITHER
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE SUPPLIER
ALLOWANCES TO CORRECT FOR THE
BANK ALLOWANCES AS THEY'VE
THEY'VE BEEN DOING IN THE- OF
THE E. U. WITH THEIR MARKET
STABILITY RESERVE IS A
CORRECTION FOR EARLY OVER SUPPLY
AND ALSO IN THE- RED YOU PROGRAM
IN THE NORTHEAST THE REGIONAL
GREENHOUSE GAS INITIATIVE THEY-
ESSENTIALLY DID A CORRECTION TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE AMOUNT OF THE
BANK IN THE INITIAL. FACE SO
EITHER THAT OR OR SOME SORT OF
ADJUSTMENT TO THE PRICE COLLAR.
MISLI I SUGGESTED PERHAPS
LINKING THE FLOOR TO WHETHER OR
NOT WE'RE ON TRACK WITH OUR
OVERALL GOAL GOAL SO IF WE'RE ON
TRACK WE DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A
CARBON PRICE GO UP MORE QUICKLY
BUT IF WE'RE NOT ON TRACK AND WE
WANT TO RELY ON THE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM AS A BACKSTOP AS-
CURRENT STRATEGY DOES THAT IT
SHOULD BE MORE DIRECTLY LINKED.
TO WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE ON TRACK
OVERALL. RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
YEAH I THAT AND AS YOU SAY BOTH
THE READY MARKET IN THE EUROPEAN
MARKET THAT HAD DONE COURSE
CORRECTIONS. TO ADDRESS THIS
OVERSUPPLY ISSUE THAT WE ALSO
HAVE- THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
LASTLY JUST. APPRECIATE THIS
BECAUSE TALK ABOUT TRANSMISSION
AND MY COLLEAGUES FOR BRINGING
THAT UP I. I DO BELIEVE IT'S
ACTUALLY IMPERATIVE THAT WE-
MAKE PROGRESS ON TRANSMISSION
THIS YEAR. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
I DON'T KNOW IF OF. DR A MAY
FEEL THIS IS STILL ONLINE. YES
I'M STILL HERE YES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. WE REALLY
APPRECIATE TO SO- MAYBE IF WE
CAN. GO BACK TO. THE. THE
NATIONAL PICTURE THAT THAT YOU
HAD TO. PRESENTED WITH YOUR YOUR
REPORT- CAN YOU TALK ABOUT THE-
YOU KNOW WE WE'VE WE'VE HEARD A
LOT OF CALLS IN AND CALIFORNIA
WEEK YOU KNOW IN CALIFORNIA WE
LIKE TO THINK OURSELVES IS AS
LEADING AND THE FIGHT AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE BUT YOU KNOW WE
ARE SHARING THESE REMINDERS THAT
WE MAY NOT BE ON TRACK WITH THE
THESE THESE GOALS THAT WITH
THEIR THAT WE'VE SET FOR
OURSELVES. MMHM WHAT. WHAT ARE
THE OPPORTUNITIES AND TRADE OFFS
OF PLANNING PLANNING FOR CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
VERSUS TWENTY FORTY FIVE. SO I
SHOULD BE CLEAR THAT WE MODEL
THE- TO US BUT NET ZERO BY
TWENTY FIFTY AND THAT WAS US
WIDE RIGHT SO THERE'S ALSO KIND
OF. WITHIN THAT FRAMEWORK
FLEXIBILITY OF WHERE THINGS ARE
CITED SO TO ME THAT TARGETS NOT
JUST CALIFORNIA ALONE IT'S- YOU
COULD PREFERENTIALLY SITE THINGS
WHERE THERE MIGHT BE ON- FEDERAL
RESOURCES OR LOWER CONSTRAINTS
WITH RESPECT TO TRANSMISSION ARE
OR OR OTHERWISE. IT WITH RESPECT
TO THOUGH. THOUGH BUILDING THE
TARGET TO TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
WHICH WE DID WE WERE NOT
MODELING- BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
MODELING STATE SPECIFIC POLICIES
RATHER A FEDERAL POLICY. MANY OF
THE SAME CONSTRAINTS ARISE AS
THEY WOULD IN A TWENTY FIFTY
EIGHT RIGHT SO TRANSMISSION RATE
REMAINS A CONSTRAINT AS MANY OF.
USTHAT ALREADY- AND THAT AGAIN
IS A REGIONAL ISSUE NOT A
CALIFORNIA ISSUE WE ALSO SAY
WHEN WE'RE THINKING ABOUT
SEQUENCING OF CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ALSO IMPORTANT
WHEN THINKING OF A NEAR TERM-
BUT TARGET AND THAT IS NOT JUST
RELATED TO TRANSMISSION AND
RENEWABLES. THAT'S ALSO RELATED
TO THINGS LIKE CARBON CAPTURE
WHERE YOU NEED A CAR WITH. US
YOU TO TRANSMISSION. BACKBONE
TWO HUNDRED AND SUPPORT KIND OF
RE POWERING THE FACILITIES OR
CONVERSION OF FACILITIES WITH
WITH CARBON CAPTURE AND ALSO SAY
OTHER THINGS THAT HAVE TO OCCUR
IN THAT SEQUENCE IS BUILDING UP
APPROPRIATE MANUFACTURING
CAPACITY TO SUPPORT KIND OF THE
BUILD OUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
OFFSHORE WIND IT'S NOT JUST
FINDING KIND OF VIABLE SITES FOR
OFFSHORE WIND OR HAVING- IT
READILY GRADING CONNECTED IT'S
ALSO HAVING THE MANUFACTURING
CAPACITY TO- ASSEMBLE WENT
URBAN. WHO ARE SHOWING A
SPECIALLY OR WHEN AND LAN BASED
WHEN MOST MANUFACTURING
CURRENTLY- IN THE U. IN THE US
MORE BROADLY IS DOMESTIC 80% OF
OUR WIND TURBINES- THAT WE
DEPLOY I'VE BEEN MANUFACTURING
DOMESTICALLY JUST BECAUSE OF.
THE THIS IS A LARGE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT YOU'RE
BUILDING IT HAS TO BE PROXIMATE. TO WHERE YOU'RE DEPLOYING. SO
THOSE ARE CRITICAL PIECES AT THE
WELL THE FACT SIDE NOT APPLY ON
. HER FIRST SOLO ALTHOUGH IT'S
AND IT'S SITUATION GIVEN THAT
KIND OF LOS OF OUR PRODUCTS ARE
ARE- IN. A THIS CHAIN AND MOST
OF THE CREDIT MATERIALS IS WELL
. MMHM SO KIND OF NEAR TERM.
TARGET OR EVEN OF A TWENTY FIFTY
TARGET WHICH- WE WANT THESE ARE
CONSTRAINTS THERE'S CAN OF THE
GREAT OF THESE ROUTE OF THE SO
CHAIN AND- I THINK. INTEREST. I
NOTED THAT- THAT IN YOUR REPORT
. YOU ALSO. OUR HIGHLIGHT. THE
NEED FOR. AUG AND CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE OF. DID YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS IN TERMS OF. HOW YOU
KNOW TO WHAT EXTENT. THE
TECHNOLOGY BASED CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE IS GOING TO BE
NECESSARY FOR ANY PATHWAY TO GET
INTO CARBON NEUTRALITY. AS MANY
OTHERS HAVE ALREADY SAID THAT IT
IS ONE OF THE TOOLS WITHIN IN
THE TOOLBOX- BUT OF COURSE THAT
COMES WITH AND WE HAVE AN OF IT
THAT DEMONSTRATED TECHNOLOGY BUT
THERE'S ALSO ON THAT SIDE OF
REGULATION AND ENSURING-
APPROPRIATE MEASUREMENT
MONITORING VERIFICATION
PROTOCOLS RELATED TO THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE. I WOULD ALSO SAY
THAT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING MOST OF
- OF THE CONVERSATION REGARDING
CARBON CAPTURE IS RETIRING
EXISTING FACILITIES AND WHERE
THERE ALREADY EXISTS IN EQUITIES
AND WHERE THOSE FACILITIES ARE
CITED AND THE AIR POLLUTION AND
OTHER IMPACTS. THAT ARE IN THE
INCLUDING KIND OF HAZARDOUS
WASTE- REMEDIATION FROM THOSE
FACILITIES- THERE IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REGARD THOSE
FACILITIES TO REDUCE AIR QUALITY
IMPACTS AND OTHER NEGATIVE
IMPACTS WITHIN THOSE COMMUNITIES
BUT IT DOESN'T KIND OF INSURANCE
PREVENT. FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AND
SO THAT'S ANOTHER CONSIDERATION
AS WELL. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR ANY OF
OUR- OTHER PANELISTS- WE JUST
MAKE SURE I. COVERED EVERYTHING
HERE. OKAY WELL THANK YO ALL TO
ALL OF OUR PANELISTS- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO STAYING IN TOUCH AND-
YOU KNOW I JUST WANNA
HIGHLIGHTED- YOU KNOW DOCTOR
KAMAN YOU KNOW SUMMARIZING IN
WRITING GO URGENT
RECOMMENDATIONS I MEAN THAT THIS
IS THE KIND OF STUFF IT'S A
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL FOR ALL OF
US IN IN IN IN IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND SO. YOU KNOW WE
HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ALL OF YOU YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF LIKE SPECIFIC POLICY
PROPOSALS THAT THE THAT THE-
THAT WE CAN DO TO ACCELERATE OUR
OUR CLIMATE ACTION WE WOULD VERY
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED ALSO THANK
YOU TO EACH AND EVERYONE OF OUR-
OUR OUR SPEAKERS TODAY. WE'RE
GOING TO. NOW OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT- I DON'T KNOW UP
. WE HAVE TO IN THE ROOM WHAT
WE'LL START WITH THE TWO IN THE
ROOM AND THEN- WE WILL OPEN UP
OUR PHONE NUMBER FOUR FOR A-
PARTICIPATING BY PHONE THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER AGAIN IS.
877-692-8957 THAT'S.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. AGAIN ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO- I'D LIKE
TO IN THE INTEREST OF TIMEWE-
ASK EACH. PUBLIC COMMENT TO BE
LIMITED TO ONE MINUTE. SIR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU YEAH
ADAM SMITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON EDISON SUPPORTS NEWSOM'S
CARBON NEUTRALITY EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND WE'D SUPPORT SEEING
THAT ENSHRINED IN LAW. ABOUT AS
YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO THE
PRESENTATIONS TODAY AND EVEN
FROM OUR OWN WORK IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR THAT THE ELECTRIC SECTOR
AND EDISON AS AN ALL ELECTRIC
UTILITY WE REALIZE THERE'S A LOT
OF WORK THAT THE ELECTRIC SYSTEM
IS GOING TO NEED TO DO. TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE AND SO WE ENCOURAGE
THIS COMMITTEE AND OTHER
COMMITTEES THIS YEAR AS YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT YOU KNOW
INCREASING AMBITION OR THINGS
THE ELECTRIC SECTOR THINGS THE
STATE CAN DO TO ENSURE WE'RE ON
THE RIGHT TRACK. LET'S TAKE
ANOTHER HARD LOOK AT HOW
FORECASTING ELECTRIC SYSTEM
PLANNING AND ALL THAT'S COMING
TOGETHER BECAUSE IF WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE HUGE LEVELS OF ADOPTION
OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES SIGNIFICANT
BUILDING ELECTRIFICATION YOU
KNOW OUR LOTUS COULD
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE WE NEED
MORE TRANSMISSION WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO START PLANNING AND START
BUILDING. NOW TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE MEETING THE NEEDS OF THE
FUTURE SO MAYBE WITH THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR TIME TO THE-
THAT'S BECAUSE THIS. RIGHT
MCGILL'S GARLAND WITH WALKER
GROUP YOU HAVE TO CALIFORNIA
HEALTH ENVIRONMENT BOUNCE
BUSINESS. TO WITH REGARDS TO
DISCUSSIONS AROUND CARBON
NEUTRALITY- I THINK WE HEARD
TODAY THAT INDIVIDUAL GOALS AND
AMBITION ALSO REQUIRED
ADDITIONAL ABILITIES TO BUILD.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
THIS CONVERSATION THAT WE
PROVIDE THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE THE ULTIMATE GOAL. WHICH
MEANS WE NEED A PERMIT FASTER
AND BUILD FASTER THAN WE EVER
HAVE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S INTEGRAL TO THIS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE AROUND
WHAT THOSE TARGETS AND WHAT
THOSE GOALS MAY BE. GOING FOR
THIS INCLUDES DISTRIBUTION AND
TRANSMISSION OF CLEAN MALL KILLS
AND ELECTRONS- TO DISTRIBUTE IT
AND USES. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
WE MAY NOT KNOW IT DOESN'T USES
ARE TODAY BUT IS FAIRLY LOW GREG
AT STRATEGY TO. UPGRADE THE
SYSTEM TO DELIVER MOLECULES AND
ELECTRONS THAT ARE CLEAN AND
RENEWABLE TODAY. AND THEN WITH
YOUR INDULGENCE REAL QUICK I'LL
PUT ON A DIFFERENT HAT WITH
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COLLISION
AND TO ASSEMBLY WOMAN KRIOS.
COMMENTS ABOUT WHAT DO WE DO
ABOUT LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
THAT MAY NOT HAVE ELECTRICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE OR THE ABILITY
PARKING GARAGES IN CHARGE.
HYDROGEN PROVIDES A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE FOLKS. TO
HAVE COST EFFECTIVE VEHICLES THE
TOP TWO MANUFACTURERS OF
AUTOMOBILE SALES IN STATE
CALIFORNIA BOTH ALL IN ON
HYDROGEN ELECTRICVEHICLES. AND
WE WANT TO DELIVER CLEAN MALL
KILLS TO THE FOLKS WHO MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO BE SERVED BY THE IN
HOME CHARGING SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT
TO. OPERATOR. TO WE HAVE- ANY
CALLS IN THE QUEUE. YOU FOR ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
FIRST LINE LINE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO TO THE STATE OF
NEW YORK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
PROJECT CONTABILIDADE. I DON'T
THINK THE MEMBERS AND PANELISTS
TYPICALLY NEED TO FUNDAMENTALLY
SHIFT ECONOMIC ACTIVITIES AND
NOT JUST GRABBED THE POLLUTING
FUELS WE LIVE. WITHIN OUR
ECONOMY TODAY FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF WORLD AND THEN
BACK IN THE CALIFORNIA AND
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN THE PANEL
CAN VALLEY SCALING ARE INVESTING
INTO CVS IS NOT A VIABLE
SOLUTION. WE CANNOT IGNORE THAT
CD I REALIZED UNVARYING CLEARLY
UNDESIRABLE TOXIC MATERIAL
UNDERGROUND YEAH RESIDENTIAL
COMMUNITIES. SURROUNDED BY
DIFFERENT QUESTION POLLUTION AND
WITH AND WITH UNJUSTLY BLASTER
POLITICAL. POWER I. YOU PRETTY.
OF THE KIND OF MEDICARE BELIEVE
. IF CURRENT PROPOSAL COULD NOT
TO MENTAL RELY COMPANY WELL X.
NOT OF THE INDUSTRY'S CARE ACT.
THE MANAGED. AND CON THIRTY
FIFTY YEARS I AT THE ON THIRTY.
IS NOT A SIX. IN AVOIDANCE THE
NECKLACE. NAMIK CHIU ME THAT THE
STATE CAN SHE- TO INVEST KERR
NOW. BUILDING ELECTRIC MICHAEL
GRANT ROWAN AND AQUATIC
COMMITTING THE- INVESTING IN
THAT TRUNK WITH THE- INVESTING
THE PAST OF LOCAL COMEDIAN. IT
WITH THE WHAT FUTURE THE MIDDLE
ECONOMY LOOK LIKE. WE MUST ALSO
BE CLEAR THAT THE TECHNOLOGY IS
NOT ACTUALLY POLICE AND WARMING
GAS. THE CRIME AND WANTED ABOUT
THE LARGER. CRY. THE SEATTLE NOT
HELPING GROW GOING.
WELL FOR HOW DO YOU CAPTURE
DOCTOR UNTIL IT'S ACTUALLY IN
THE CAPITAL I DON'T WISH DECADE
FROM NOW WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
DEVELOPING EQUITABLE COMMUNITY
POLICY. MAKERS JUST TRANSITION A
REALITY AS OPEN TODAY JERRY
FEDERAL AND CORPORATE PRESIDENT
ACT OF THE BENEFITS OF THE
ECONOMY AT THE SAME TIME AS
EVERYONE ELSE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU I. FORGOT TO STATE EARLIER
THAT- THIS COMMITTEE THIS JOINT
COMMITTEE WILL BE. CONDUCTING.
OUR OUR NEXT HEARING. I OUR WAY
IF HERE ON ON K. AND THE FOLKS
ON CAR CAPTURE AND STORAGE AND
WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT. THAT ALL
STAKEHOLDERS- IN OUR REPRESENTED
AND THAT HEARING- OPERATOR NEXT
TO. CALL THE POLICE. GET A COME
FROM MY TWENTY TWO YEAR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BEN GRANTED I'M PROVIDING COMING
ON BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA I'M ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENT
IN ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
DECARBONIZATION EFFORTS. AND
CLEAN ENERGY ESPECIALLY
INVESTMENT IN OFFSHORE WIND
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES AND
POLISH STORAGE THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE MUST ACCELERATE THE
CONDITION AWAY FROM PUBLIC
YOU'LL- AN ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT DAN CAME AND
CALLED FOR AN ACCELERATED 1100%
EVEY TIME LINE TO TWENTY THIRTY
YEAR EARLIER. AGGRESSIVE
MOVEMENT FOR IT ON OFFSHORE WIND
AND A CONTINUED PROTECTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S ROOFTOP SOLAR
INDUSTRY. EMITTING A COLOR TAX
MAKING GROUP SOLAR EXPENSIVE IS
NOT THE PATHWAY TO ENSURING THE
PAUL. ADDITIONALLY LEFT IN OUR
HELPING INVESTMENT AND THAT
INTRODUCTION- WILL SLOW DOWN OR
SPEED CONDITION THEIR MISSION
TRANSPORTATION. CALIFORNIA THE
WORST AIR QUALITY OF ANY STATE
IN THE COUNTRY IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. FOR OVER
50% OF. THAT INTRODUCED THE
TOPIC TAILPIPE EMISSIONS OF
WELL. AND AT BOTH CONTENT THE IN
A COLD BUFFET CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA LET'S. NOT TAKE FULL
ADVANTAGE. STOLAR IN OFFSHORE
WIND NOW. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND OUR NEXT QUESTION
WILL COME FROM ONE NINE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON THAT THE BILL
IS ON TRACK FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
NOW CALL CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS. AND I WANT
TO THANK THIS COMMITTEE FOR
PRIORITIZING THIS ISSUE IN THIS
DISCUSSION. AND WANTED TO URGE.
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THAT
AS WE DEPLOY SOLUTION TO CUT OUR
EMISSIONS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT FOR REDUCING OUR RELIANCE
ON FOSSIL FUELS AND THE
POLLUTION THAT THAT IMPOSES. ON
THE COMMUNITIES WHERE IT FRIDAY
SO IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE'RE
GONNA CENTER EQUITY WHEN IT
DRAFTING THE CLIMATE CRISIS THAT
WE ARE PRIORITIZING POLICIES AND
INVESTMENTS. THAT REDUCE
EMISSIONS IN THE NEAR TERM AND
ENSURE WOULD REDUCING POLLUTION
BUT ECONOMY RESIDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE. AND I WANT TO START THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO CARBON CAPTURE
AND STORAGE IT SHOULD BE STATED
IN MANY CASES BUT NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS CARBON
SEQUESTRATION IF TECHNICALLY
MUCH CHEAPER TO IMPLEMENT. AND
DIRECT AIR CAPTURE AND HOW THE
MULTITUDE OF COKE BENEFITS NOT
PROVIDED BY OTHER TECHNOLOGY NOT
THE LEAST OF WHICH IS
INTRODUCTION OF POLLUTION AND
ENHANCEMENT OF AIR QUALITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE
COUNCIL STATED I THINK WE HAVE
SOLUTIONS THAT COULD CREATE HIGH
QUALITY JOBS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BY FOCUSING OUR
INVESTMENTS IN RENEWABLE ENERGY
PRODUCTION AND STORAGE BUT I
WANT TO ADVOCATE FOR
PRIORITIZING PUBLIC DOLLARS. AND
RESOURCES THAN THOSE PROVEN
SOLUTION EVEN IF IT MAY BE MORE
EXPENSIVE AS- EXPENSIVE AS LONG
AS IT REDUCES OUR DEPENDENCE ON
FOSSIL FUEL AND PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES FROM POLLUTION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK NEXT
WILL GO LINE. LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS DAN MAY MUSTAPHA
TWENTY FOR THIS ANDREAS POVERTY
IN ENVIRONMENT COURSE P. ON HIS
BEHALF AND SPEAK TODAY. IN SHORT
- TWO CF THAT WORK MOST PROJECTS
IN NORTH AMERICA HEAVILY
SUBSIDIZED DOWN A NUMBER OPENED
NEWS THAT ARE RUNNING FAILED TO
MEET THEIR PROMISED. THAT SUCH
SPENDING ON PCS IS A BAD
INVESTMENT IN DEPRIVED ACTUAL
CRIMES SOLUTION TO NEEDED
FUNDING FOR THE FOR COMMUNITIES
LIVING NEAR EXISTING FOSSIL FUEL
INFRASTRUCTURE NOT ONLY TO THE
TECHNOLOGY PERPETUATE EXISTING
HARMS. EXACERBATE THEM WITHOUT
ACTUAL CLIMATE BENEFITS FURTHER
PIPELINES LEAK SUFFOCATING COME
BACKSIDE GAS INTO THE ATMOSPHERE
AND INTO COMMUNITIES AND STORAGE
IS COMPLETELY UNTESTED AND
UNPROVEN OVER RELEVANT COUNTRIES
LONG TIME LINES. EVEN WORSE THE
SUPPOSED CRIME INTERVENTION IS
OVERWHELMINGLY YEARS TO CUT
CARBON DIOXIDE FOR ENHANCED OIL
RECOVERY WHICH IS ITSELF
INCREDIBLY HARMFUL FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. AND IT OUTWEIGHS
WHATEVER DUBIOUS CLIMATE BENEFIT
CCS MIGHT CLAIM TO PROVIDE.
RESULTING IN FURTHER DOWNSTREAM
EMISSIONS BY SOME ESTIMATES
CAUSING CCS TO INCREASE NET
CARBON EMISSIONS BY A FACTOR OF
FIVE. IN OTHER WORDS CCS WAS
DEVELOPED BY WILLING GAS
COMPANIES TO TRICK POLICYMAKERS
AND THE PUBLIC INTO FUNDING FOR
THE CLIMATE HARM AND
ENVIRONMENTAL INJUSTICE PURELY
FOR THEIR OWN PROFIT. IF THE
STATE INSIST ON MARCHING BLINDLY
DOWN THE SOUTH POLE PASSED HERE
P. AND MANY OF OUR ENVIRONMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALLIES
WOULD LOVE TO BE AT THE TABLE TO
DISCUSS WHAT WE CAN DO TO LIMIT
HARM TO OUR COMMUNITIES. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE DISCUSSION
ON. THIS TOPIC THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I LITTLE
TWENTY ONE YEAR IS OPEN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SHARE THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS GERRY HUGHES I AM OF THE
AMERICAS PROGRAM COORDINATOR
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATION MARKETWATCH AND
I'VE FOUND THAT I HEARING TO BE
VERY INTERESTING THERE'S BEEN
SOME REALLY INTERESTING
DISCUSSION ABOUT MANY TOPICS BUT
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
GRASS BEING FOR TECHNOLOGICAL
FIXES IT'S COMING FROM THIS
COMMITTEE IN TERMS OF PURSUING
UNPROVEN HIGH RISK TYPE
TECHNOLOGIES IN PARTICULAR THOSE
OF CARBON DIOXIDE REMOVAL
INTEREST IN SUCH HIGH RISK
TECHNOLOGIES HAS GROWN IN MANY
CIRCLES. AND EVEN MORE NOTABLY
INCLUDING INDUSTRIES SUCH AS THE
ALSO FUEL INDUSTRY MINING
AVIATION AND AS WELL SILICON
VALLEY HOWEVER THE LATEST IPCC
REPORT CLIENTS THAT THESE
TECHNOLOGIES COULD TRIGGER
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS IF YOU CAN
BELIEVE IN VULNERABLE PARTS OF
THE WORLD THEY WOULD INTRODUCE A
RANGE OF NEW GREGIS HAZARDS TO
PEOPLE AND ECOSYSTEMS LARGE
SCALE TECHNOLOGICAL CTR
JEOPARDIZES PEOPLE SYSTEMS
BIODIVERSITY FOOD AND WATER
SECURITY LIVELIHOODS AND LAND
RIGHT TO TAKE A LOOK FOR
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SPECIAL REPORT FROM THE I. P. C.
C. R. ONE POINT FIVE DEGREES
CELSIUS CAUTIONED AGAINST HEAVY
RELIANCE ON CD ARE STRONGLY
QUESTIONING THE SOCIAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL FEASIBILITY I
THOUGHT A LITTLE BIT
DISAPPOINTED WITH THIS HEARING
THAT THERE WAS NOT A MORE
DIVERSITY OF VOICES ON THESE
MATTERS AND THE LAST THING I
WANT FLAG AS FAR AS
DECARBONIZATION GOES HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS THAT
THERE IS A VERY STRONG AND VERY
POLITICALLY SUPPORTED PIVOTAL
LIQUID BIOFUELS HAPPENING IN THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA. AND
WE'VE BEEN CAUSING A LOT OF
EVIDENCE ABOUT DEPENDENT ON HIGH
DEFORESTATION RISK COMMODITIES
LIKE SOY AS A FEEDSTOCK FOR
LIQUID BIOFUELS IS NOT THE KIND
OF SOLUTION SO I REALLY THINK
THAT THIS COMMITTEE NEEDS TO
TAKE A STEP BACK AND TAKE A LOOK
A HARD LOOK AT THE MECHANISMS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN IN PLACE
BEFORE GOING FURTHER DOWN THE
PATHWAYS ABOUT IMAGINARY.
TECHNOLOGIES THANK YOU THANK YOU
. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO FOR.
PUBLIC IF YOU THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
ALL AND THIS NEW HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.